[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour suivre
cette neuvième journée de débat sur la
réforme des retraites ici au Sénat les
équipes de Public Sénat continuent à
vous faire vivre ce véritable marathon
parlementaire toute la journée vous
pourrez suivre de nouveau les débats en
direct sur notre antenne et sur notre
site public sénat.fr alors hier le Sénat
adopté l'article 8 du texte qui prévoit
notamment des départs anticipés pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
les sénateurs ont ensuite commencé à
l'examen de l'article 9 qui parle des
questions de pénibilité et à ce moment
là et bien les débats se sont
véritablement tendus et pour en parler
on va retrouver Quentin calmé dans la
tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin
on a encore eu une soirée électrique au
Sénat oui bonjour Alexandre bonjour à
tous effectivement on est passé à
l'article 9 celui sur la prise en compte
de la pénibilité la droite a voulu
accélérer les débats c'est ça qui s'est
joué en fait en séance hier elle a le
droit a voulu accélérer les débats et
faire tomber c'est à dire supprimer une
myriade d'amendements venus de la gauche
patatras cette gauche sénatoriale a
refusé de se laisser faire écouter
Claude reynalyer en séance
je vous signale simplement un seul mot
il y a 70 amendements qui vont tomber ça
aurait fait 70 prises de parole sur le
sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
on va le remplacer par 70 règles
rappels du règlement c'est intelligent
et c'est de droit alors cette
intelligent moi j'aimerais plutôt qu'on
enlève ça et qu'on travaille au fond
voilà travailler au fond ça a été assez
peu fait hier on a assez peu parlé
pénibilité on a plutôt vu des échanges
très musclés une vif tension entre la
droite et la gauche avec de multiples de
très nombreux rappellent aux règlements
écoutez le rapporteur René Paul Savary
pour lui la gauche refuse d'avancer
contrairement à ce qu'elle aurait promis
initialement en effet le Sénat devait
attendre la mobilisation du 7 mars pour
examiner l'article 7 et bien la gauche
refuserait de respecter cette promesse
écouter le
olte mais
vous et vous avez récolter vous récoltez
ce que vous avez semé la semaine
dernière
vous avez
vous n'avez pas tenu vos engagements et
quand on tient pas les engagements
demandez à vos présidents de groupe ils
savent bien de quoi je parle
demandez-leur ne criez pas comme ça
tenez-vous engagements il était bien
question que l'on puisse débattre du
texte pour aller jusqu'au bout du texte
voilà tenez vos engagements à dire leur
apporteur de la branche vieillesse
peut-être que d'ailleurs et Guillaume
Gontard pourra répondre à votre micro
Alexandre mais finalement un amendement
de la droite et du centre a bien été
adopté en fin de séance vers minuit et
demi mais le débat autour de la
pénibilité ne fait que commencer et on
se doute que les tensions dans
l'hémicycle aussi Alex merci beaucoup
Quentin il faut dire aussi que hier soir
la véritable nouveauté dans ses débats
au Sénat c'est que le gouvernement a
utilisé l'article 44 alinéa 2 de la
Constitution pour rejeter des
amendements des sous amendements
précisément qui ont été déposés par la
gauche sénatoriale qui n'avait pas
encore été examinée par la commission et
donc le gouvernement a demandé qu'il ne
soit pas examiné donc ça c'est un fait
nouveau dans ces débats tendus au Sénat
justement pour en parler j'accueille sur
ce plateau Guillaume Gontard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes président du groupe
écologiste au Sénat peut-être une
première réaction sur le fait que ça y
est le gouvernement utilise aussi et
bien des outils constitutionnels pour
accélérer les débats au Sénat bah oui
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir hier soir
bah je sais pas dans quelles conditions
est le gouvernement et puis la majorité
sénatoriale mais voilà sa volonté c'est
de bloquer le débat quelque part quand
même parce que ce qui s'est passé hier
soir c'est je le dis c'est de la droite
sénatoriale avec le gouvernement
bordélisme débat et je pense que c'est
particulièrement grave parce que hier
soir de quoi en parler la pénibilité au
travail on avait un certain nombre
d'amendements de la gauche des
écologistes sur cette question de
pénibilité et sur les risques chimiques
technologiques sont des charges lourdes
et bien voilà le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas que l'on parle de ça parce
que
il ne souhaite pas que l'on parle de ce
texte parce qu'il n'est pas à l'aise
parce qu'on est dans une imprécision
totale donc on utilise maintenant le 44
de on a fait le 47 on a fait l'article
42 l'article 38 je pense qu'on va passer
par tous les tous les chiffres à la fois
de la Constitution et du Règlement du
Sénat pour bâillonner bâillonner le
Sénat Bayonnais le Parlement Bailleul et
le travail parlementaire je pense
franchement que ce n'est pas sérieux ce
n'est vraiment pas sérieux je pense que
nous on est prêt à débattre et on a
toujours été on a des amendements des
amendements de fonds alors oui on nous
parle de sous-amendement qui ont été
déposés mais pourquoi on a fait ça
puisqu'on nous retire à chaque fois
l'ensemble de nos amendements pourquoi
on ne peut pas continuer à riposte c'est
une riposte en quelque sorte quand vous
déposez des sous amendements pour
contrer les amendements le droit
d'amendements c'est un droit
parlementaire strict quand on dépose les
amendements qu'ensuite on nous les
retire avec durée des artifices on est
bien obligé de un moment donné de
riposter parce que oui on a des choses à
on a des choses à dire donc je pense que
c'est on est vraiment dans une situation
inacceptable et moi franchement je suis
je dis je suis triste de ce qui de ce
qui se passe de l'image que l'on peut
donner on a des gens qui sont dans dans
la rue on a des syndicats uniques qui
attendent une réponse je le rappelle un
courrier a été envoyé au président de la
République où est le président de la
République pour recevoir les syndicats
bah oui bah ils attendent toujours une
réponse jusqu'à quand on va on va être
dans cette situation je pense qu'à un
moment donné il va falloir que le
gouvernement se ressaisisse que la
majorité sénatoriale serait saisissent
parce que là ça ne va pas du tout alors
en réponse est bien la droite
sénatoriale estime que les sénateurs de
gauche font je cite de l'obstruction et
hier soir le rapporteur du texte le
sénateur les républicains René Paul
Savary a parlé d'un accord entre les
différents présidents de groupe
politique entre la droite et la gauche
pour qu'il y ait l'examen de ce fameux
article 7 sur les 64 ans après les
manifestations du 7 mars et en échange
les sénateurs de gauche acceptaient et
bien d'accélérer un petit peu les débats
pour aller au bout de cette réforme des
retraites avant Dimanche soir est-ce
qu'il y a eu cet accord et est-ce que
vous ne l'avez pas respecter moi je l'ai
dit très clairement s'il y avait un
accord d'ailleurs ce serait grave pas
d'accord on a un texte on débat d'un
texte avec des articles évidemment qu'on
allait arriver à l'article 7 enfin je
veux dire qui ne pensait qu'on
arriverait pas à l'article 7 vu le
nombre d'amendements parce que encore
une fois un peu plus de 3000 amendements
déposé au début du texte par l'ensemble
des sénateurs sur ces 3000 amendements
c'est un peu plus de 1000 par la droite
donc on est très très loin de
l'obstruction donc on veut nous faire
croire que ça que c'est de l'obstruction
que c'est de l'obstruction en fait ce
qui se passe tout simplement c'est
qu'ils ne veulent pas débat du texte un
exemple l'amendement de Monsieur
Retailleau pour revenir sur la clause
grand-père qui fait beaucoup débats et
ben en fait sur la suppression des
régimes spéciales suppression des
régimes du régime spéciaux ils devaient
être avant-hier soir ensuite hier matin
maintenant on voit qu'il aurait poussé
qu'il est repoussait parce qu'il n'a pas
de majorité parce que sa majorité se
fissure quand on voit le vote sur
l'article sur l'article 7 justement pour
passer de 62 à 64 ans c'est quand même
intéressant de voir que ça va bien
au-delà de la gauche même dans les rangs
dans marche du groupe RDPI on a deux
personnes qui se sont qui se sont
absolus donc petit à petit oui cette
majorité se fissure petit à petit quand
on avance le texte on s'aperçoit que
c'est un mauvais texte que c'est un coup
dur porté aux françaises et aux Français
et donc ils ne veulent pas aller plus
loin et donc ils font tout pour qu'on ne
puisse pas justement continuer ce débat
parlementaire c'est un vrai aveu de
faiblesse est-ce que vous craignez que
le gouvernement utilise finalement
l'arme constitutionnelle ultime dans ce
débat au Sénat c'est l'article 44 alinéa
3 de la Constitution qu'on appelle
l'article du vote bloqué en gros si le
gouvernement utilise cet article et bien
les sénateurs devront voter directement
sur cette réforme des retraites avec les
amendements choisis par le gouvernement
vous craignez que l'exécutif l'utilise
je je le crains et en tout cas
évidemment que un moment donné il
utilisera certainement je dirais ils
sont ils sont prêts à tout et on a fait
tous les tous les chiffres de la
Constitution pour essayer de bloquer le
débat parlementaire donc oui toute façon
que ça soit Emmanuel Macron que ça soit
ce gouvernement que ça soit de la droite
scénarioale il voudrait gouverner tout
seul parce que eux tout seul ont raison
ah non ça se passe pas comme ça on est
dans une démocratie on est au Parlement
et ben au Parlement on travaille on
propose des amendements on fait des
propositions on construit on construit
un texte il va falloir qu'ils le
comprenne en tout cas nous on sera là
jusqu'à dimanche soir minuit et on va
tenir effectivement le siège Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail dénonce je
cite une mélanchonisation de la gauche
équatoriale comment vous prenez cette
critique
vous savez quand on quand on en est là
franchement moi j'ai posé des questions
à lui faisait du socle puisque on n'y
comprend rien si par exemple sur les
carrières longues quelqu'un a compris
moi j'aimerais retourner en Isère et
toutes les questions qu'on me pose de
savoir mais à quel âge on me dit
monsieur le sénateur à quel âge je vais
partir à la retraite personne j'y
comprends rien j'ai ça n'a apporté
aucune réponse donc quand on pose des
questions il rencontre il répond
Mélenchon franchement c'est un peu
faible merci beaucoup à Guillaume
Montard d'être venu ce matin sur le
plateau de Public Sénat avant la reprise
de ces débats en séance dans une minute
maintenant sur cette réforme des
retraites justement on va retrouver
Quentin dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
Quentin les sénateurs vont débattre de
l'article 9 de cette réforme des
retraites qui concerne la pénibilité oui
Alexandre un petit mot pour commencer
sur l'ambiance regardez les sénateurs
qui sont en train de s'installer Olivier
du soft qui arrive juste ici qui vient
de saluer la rapporteur général Franck
Riester le ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement qui est en train de
s'installer au banc des ministres le
bord des ministres qui se trouve juste
ici le banc de la commission qui se
trouve juste là alors effectivement le
la pénibilité c'est ce qui va être au
cœur de ces échanges toute la matinée
Alexandre alors hier il y a déjà eu le
alentours d'un fond qui va comme cela
permettre de travailler à la prévention
des de la pénibilité mais on va voir
maintenant d'autres débats autour du
déplafonnement du compte professionnel
de prévention et on va voir sur tout
Alexandre à la gauche la gauche qui va
essayer de réinstaurer des critères de
pénibilité des critères de pénibilité
qui existaient dans la loi Touraine et
qui ont été supprimés par Emmanuel
Macron en l'occurrence en l'occurrence
ces gouvernements en 2017 Alexandre donc
ce sont ces débats sur la pénibilité que
l'on va pouvoir suivre dans quelques
secondes puisque la séance va pouvoir
commencer d'un instant à l'autre
Alexandre effectivement Quentin on va
peut-être dire un mot sur ce qui a été
voté dans la journée d'hier et
d'ailleurs Montard le président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat en parlait le
Sénat a adopté l'article 8 qui concerne
les départs anticipés à la retraite et
notamment le dispositif carrière long
d'un dispositif qui a été qualifié par
beaucoup de sénateurs hier dans le débat
de véritables
usine à gaz et oui et bien ce dispositif
carrière longue il prévoit des départs
anticipés pour les Français qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt avec plusieurs
bornes d'âge différents par exemple ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler à avancer
pour en partir à 58 ans ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18 ans
pourront partir à 60 ans et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20 ans
pourront partir à 62 ans noter que le
Sénat a voté une modification de ce
dispositif carrière longue qui avait
déjà été annoncé par la première
ministre Elisabeth borne après le vote
du Sénat hier et bien les Français qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21
ans pourront partir à 63 ans s'ils ont
bien tout leur trimestres cotisés
évidemment Quentin on va peut-être
toujours sur cette journée d'hier on
peut aussi évoquer et bien ce qui a été
voté par le Sénat pour les maires de
famille tout à fait c'est l'une des
principales avancées qui a été adopté
hier en séance même qu'on peut se
souvenir de ce scrutin Alex qui a eu
lieu vers 16h 17h
280 voix pour y compris sur les bandes
de la gauche c'est cette surcote
effectivement pour les femmes qui ont
tout leur trimestre cotisé et qui
continuent à travailler jusqu'à l'âge de
63 et voir maintenant 64 ans et bien
lorsqu'elle continue entre 63 et 64 ans
le Sénat a voté une surcote de leur
pension une forme de bonus jusqu'à 5%
par par année pour cette année
travailler en plus c'était une mesure
voulue par la droite sénatoriale écouter
le chef de fil DLR Bruno Retailleau
premier principe je disais ne pas faire
perdre aux carrières longues leur sens
pourquoi tout simplement parce que une
étude récente l'a montré désormais il y
a au moins la même espérance vie pour
ceux qui en bénéficient par rapport à
ceux qui n'en bénéficient plus on est
plus du tout dans le système que
François Fillon avait inventé justement
pour faire face à un certain nombre de
dispositifs en 2003 voilà c'était
effectivement Bruno Retailleau donc il y
a eu aussi cette surcote donc pour les
les femmes qui ont eu au moins un enfant
alors que au moment où je vous parle et
bien la présidente de séance est en
train de s'installer c'est la Radical
Nathalie Delattre qui est élu en Gironde
qui est en train de prendre place dans
l'hémicycle pour se débat sur la réforme
des retraites qui vont pouvoir commencer
d'un instant à l'autre Alexandre merci
beaucoup Quentin le Sénat qui va donc
aborder l'examen de l'article 9 de cette
réforme des retraites un article
ce qui concerne la pénibilité notamment
ce qu'on appelle le fameux compte
pénibilité avec des mesures qui sont
proposées par le gouvernement notamment
pour lutter contre les maladies
professionnelles pour faire œuvre de
prévention allez on retourne dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat c'est parti pour
cette 9e journée de débat sur la réforme
des retraites 3 dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement 33 08 au sein de l'article
9 article 9 je donne la parole à la
présidente madame de roche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
la bienvenue pour une journée que sans
nul doute sera aussi dynamique que la
soirée que nous avons connu hier et donc
madame la Présidente en application
de l'article 44 alinéa 6 du règlement la
Commission demande sur cet article 9 la
priorité d'examen de votre sur
l'amendement des rapporteurs le 21 38
pour préciser il s'agit du maintien 60
ans de l'âge de la retraite pour
incapacité permanente sujet que nous
avons largement développé en commission
je précise que cette priorité ne fait
tomber aucun amendement
nous reprendrons
s'améliore de jour en jour nous
reprendrons ensuite le cours normal de
nos débats
très bien merci madame la Présidente je
suis donc saisie d'une demande de
priorité de la Commission sur
l'amendement
2138 afin qu'il soit appelé et mis au
voie immédiatement selon l'article 44
alinéa 6 de notre règlement la priorité
est de droit quand elle est demandée par
la Commission saisie au fond sauf
opposition du gouvernement messieurs les
ministres quelle est la vie du
gouvernement sur cette demande de
priorité merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente de la Commission
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs comme
depuis le début de ce débat et
traditionnellement le gouvernement ne
s'oppose pas aux demandes de priorité de
la Commission et s'en remet au Sénat
puisque le gouvernement ne s'y oposs pas
la priorité est donc ordonnée
nous entrez oui oui madame la Présidente
il y a pas de souci nous sommes en train
de distribuer je vais attendre que la
distribution soit finalisée de
l'amendement donc 21 38 avant qu'il ne
soit présenté
par nos rapports
monsieur le rapporteur j'attends
simplement que là
voilà que l'amendement soit distribué
vous souhaitez simplement que le
rapporteur soit prêt
c'est bon je pense qu'il a été distribué
tous les sénateurs présents monsieur le
rapporteur pour présentation de cet
amendement merci effectivement
nous sommes très attachés à cette
modification proposée par Elisabeth
Doisneau et moi-même à la commission des
affaires sociales pour faire en sorte
que l'incapacité permanente soit dans le
cas des retraites anticipées pris en
compte en restant si possible dans le
droit actuel effectivement elle
s'applique des 60 ans actuellement
lorsque vous avez une incapacité par
moments un minimum auteur de 20% ou si
vous êtes entre 10 et 20% d'incapacité
permanente et vous êtes exposé un
certain nombre d'années à savoir 17 ans
pour certains facteurs d'autres facteurs
n'ont pas durées d'exposition au risque
vous pouvez bénéficier d'une retraite
anticipée deux ans avant l'âge légal
donc à partir de 60 ans donc la
commission va réfléchi à ce dispositif
ou lorsqu'on demande un effort
supplémentaire aux gens il risque
effectivement d'être plus utilisé
qu'actuellement et c'est vrai que il est
actuellement insuffisamment utilisé
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons pointer cette spécificité du
doigt vis-à-vis du du gouvernement ça
rentre dans la logique dans la logique
qui nous a animé de faire en sorte que
nous puissions répondre aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens ils
l'ont largement exprimé dans la rue et
ça c'est me semble-t-il un élément de
réponse tout à fait déterminant c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
attachés à ce à cette proposition
monsieur le ministre pour la pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas encore obtenu
satisfaction c'est que nous n'avons pas
été suffisamment
convaincant un argument supplémentaire
mais c'est peut-être une argutie
budgétaire c'est que c'est une mesure
qui relève de la branche ATMP de la
sécurité
sociale et non pas de la branche
vieillesse et dans le cas de l'équilibre
de cette réforme il ne la pénalise pas
néanmoins néanmoins c'est une dépense
supplémentaire sur les comptes publics
soyons tout à fait clair dans ce type de
dispositif mais ça nous paraît être un
élément qui peut être largement partagé
sur ses bancs où on a eu suffisamment
peut-être de division jusqu'à présent où
on peut être peut-être se rassembler sur
ce type de dispositif merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur
puis-je avoir la vie du gouvernement
peut-être un mot d'abord pour dire que
je donne acte bien volontiers à monsieur
le rapporteur que la dépense que
susciterait que créerait une telle
disposition c'est l'été adoptée n'est
pas une dépense qui concerne ce qu'on
appelle les bornes du système de
retraite puisque c'est une dépense qui
se réportait par la branche accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur ça ne
déséquilibre pas le système de retraite
est donc ça ne controvient pas à
l'objectif de retour à l'équilibre du
système de retraite il n'empêche que
c'est une dépense publique c'est une
dépense sociale portée par la bronchette
TP que nous évaluons entre 250 et 260
millions d'euros par an le gouvernement
et c'est une évaluation je précise les
choses brutes pour donner suite à mon
raisonnement le gouvernement a fait un
choix différent de celui que propose
votre commission des affaires sociales
nous avons fait le choix de maintenir
dans cette logique de relèvement des
seuils à 62 ans le départ pour
incapacité permanente mais en
élargissant de manière extrêmement
importante les critères d'accès à cette
retraite anticipée pour incapacité Perm
je ne donne qu'un exemple pour illustrer
le propos actuellement pour bénéficier
d'un départ anticipé au titre de
l'incapacité permanente il faut
justifier d'une exposition à des
facteurs de pénibilité justifiant de la
situation d'incapacité pendant 17 ans
nous avons prévu dans le texte que nous
vous proposons que cette exposition soit
ramenée de 17 à 50 de la même manière
nous avons prévu je l'ai évoqué hier je
crois le fait que ce départ anticipé
puisse être de droit pour les assurer
qui ont un taux d'incapacité reconnu
supérieur ou égal à 20% sans passer par
une seconde procédure médicale
considérons que la reconnaissance d'un
tome égale ou supérieur à 20%, vaut
d'une certaine manière avis médical
permanent si
nous suivons votre commission cela veut
dire que nous supprimons les
assouplissements que nous apportons aux
règles et nous supprimons vous
supprimeriez pardon le passage de 17 à
50 expositions pour rester sur 17 ans
d'exposition mais avec en contrepartie
un départ plutôt c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit il y a un instant que la dépense que
nous estimons entre 250 et 260 millions
d'euros est une dépense brute puisqu'il
faudrait tenir compte aussi de la
moindre dépense supprimée du fait de la
suppression pardon pour ces répétitions
des assouplissements que nous proposons
pour toutes ces raisons vous l'avez
compris la vie du gouvernement et
défavorable je dis en ayant bien en tête
que c'est un amendement qui a été adopté
par votre commission mais pour ces deux
principes à la fois le fait que nous
ayons choisi une méthode différente par
assouplissement des critères plutôt que
par bouger de l'âge nous ne pouvons que
nous opposer j'ajoute que nous sommes
dans une logique aussi de lisibilité sur
les soldages à partir desquels on peut
faire valoir le droit à tel ou tel
départ et c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour nous de donner cet
avis défavorable
monsieur le rapporteur vous souhaitiez
apporter des précisions
monsieur le ministre la durée
d'exposition pour certains facteurs de
risque pour d'autres on voit bien qu'il
y a une différence elle peut être prise
par décret donc rien ne vous empêche de
prendre le décret
rien ne vous empêche de prendre le
décret derrière pour faire en sorte que
notre proposition soit élargie
effectivement à cette réduction de la
durée d'exposition quand la commission
pluridisciplinaire qui serait
effectivement pour ceux qui ont plus de
20 % la capacité qui ne serait pas
réunies il y aura un passage
systématique d'incapacité à 20% sur une
retraite anticipée franchement c'est là
aussi une avancée que vous pouvez faire
quel que soit le vote du Sénat donc je
pense que nos mesures sont
complémentaires et j'inciterai mes
collègues bien sûr elle est soutenir
merci
merci pour explication de votre madame
la Présidente rossignol
merci madame la Présidente bonjour chers
collègues
cet amendement a beaucoup de vertus la
première c'est qu'il protège le droit au
départ en retraite à 60 ans des salariés
en incapacité permanente et la deuxième
c'est qu'il ne fait tomber aucune aucun
amendement on n'en voudrait que des
comme ça pour autant de remarques quand
même par rapport aux propos du ministre
qui dit que c'est amendement va
augmenter les dépenses c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est pas une dépense nouvelle
c'est une moindre économie sur votre
projet de réforme des retraites ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose et
c'est un transfert de charge de
l'assurance vieillesse vers la branche
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle donc il faut être qu'on
soit plus précis dans notre manière de
nous exprimer pour pas faire croire aux
gens qui nous regardent et ils sont
quand même très nombreux je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué vous aussi que nos
amendements sont des amendements
irresponsables enfin nous allons en
espèce est une du rapporteur serait des
amendements irresponsables qui ne
prendraient pas en compte
le nécessaire équilibre des dépenses
publiques la deuxième chose que que je
voulais dire c'est que en fait c'est
assez diabolique le piège dans lequel
vous essayez de nous mettre monsieur le
ministre c'est le chantage permanent si
vous votez l'amendement ça varie alors
vous supprimerez des mesures importantes
sur les deux exposition et ce chantage
là on peut pas l'accepter donc nous
allons voter l'amendement Savary et nous
dénonçons votre chantage
merci Madame Ferré pour explication de
vote
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement comme il y a de
le préciser ma collègue nous allons
voter cet amendement cet amendement qui
va de dans le bon sens car nous avons
dénoncé depuis le début de ce débat
le reportage qui nous disons sans cesse
ces deux ans de plus pour tout le monde
quel que soit la situation ce qui
partaient à 62 vont partir à 64 et ceux
qui partaient à 60 vont partir à 62 cet
amendement propose de maintenir ce
possibilité donc de départ à 60 ans ça
va vraiment dans le bon sens à reconnaît
la pénibilité et la situation parfois
extrêmement difficile pour celles et
ceux qui relèvent de ce dispositif et
non ça n'est pas une dépense nouvelle
puisque on maintient ce qui est organisé
aujourd'hui donc voilà je voulais dire
que notre groupe allait voter
favorablement cet amendement merci chers
collègues la parole est donnée au
président karucci
le ministre
franchement après
comment dire le spectacle un peu
désolant de ces derniers jours lorsqu'on
rentre sur des amendements un peu
construit
je souhaite vivement que le gouvernement
face à un effort
vous ne pouvez pas considérer que
l'équilibre de votre texte même si vous
avez déjà fait des efforts en début de
de débats sur les retraites mais
reconnaissons que
il faut encore des avancées si vous
souhaitez vouloir travailler avec le
Sénat avec l'ensemble du Sénat
il faut accepter des modifications on a
hier malgré le désordre généralisé on a
hier beaucoup insisté sur l'usure sur
les carrières très difficiles sur les
gens qui souffraient en fin de carrière
et qui avaient besoin de partir plus tôt
l'amendement du rapporteur vous permet
de dire que l'allongement que vous
souhaitez de la durée ou le report de
l'âge ne sont pas les mêmes pour tout le
monde et que clairement lorsque
quelqu'un n'est plus en situation de
travailler il faut pas le lui imposer
alors je reconnais bien volontiers que
quand vous prenez des mesures comme
celle là forcément
ça a un coût mais oui bien sûr monsieur
le ministre mais la justice et le fait
de pouvoir présenter aux Français une
réforme en disant elle est difficile
pour tout le monde parce qu'il faut
sauver les comptes publics le compte
public sur l'équilibre des retraites
mais quand même le gouvernement le Sénat
sont attentifs au fait de dire nous
savons qu'il y a des gens pour lesquels
ça n'est pas possible et nous prenons
les mesures nécessaires pour trouver des
solutions n'hésitez pas monsieur le
ministre allez prendre avec nous
[Applaudissements]
madame pense et mange pour explication
de vote
oui merci même ma présidente alors nous
aussi nous avions des arguments
construits mais ils ont tous été frappés
par l'article 40 mais là je vois
qu'effectivement vous le contournez donc
par contre comme tous mes collègues je
le soutiendrai
c'est que qu'une des mesures de
transfert de bronches transfert aux
autres branches de des effets de la
réforme là on parle de la TNT mais c'est
pas les seuls et il y a quand même des
transferts invisibilisés sur la maladie
sur la CNAM sur le chômage sur le RSA
sur les minima sociaux tout ça c'est
invisibilisé là comme vous voulez mettre
cela vous êtes obligé de rendre visible
un des transferts et je pense qu'ils
sont plutôt à hauteur de 5 milliards que
de 200 millions alors monsieur le
ministre vous dites bon le rapporteur
vous l'a dit les mesures
d'accompagnement et bien vous allez les
préserver parce que je pense que c'est
le seul souci que vous avez pour rendre
favorable votre avis vous allez les le
faire par décret mais moi je voudrais
revenir sur les 3 milliards
que vous avez mis comme mesure
d'accompagnement sur la capacité
permanente à tort puisque c'était un
maintien donc là nous avons trois
milliards de marge de manœuvre pour
mettre toutes les mesures qu'on voudrait
ajouter 250 à 300 millions là pour le
coup ça tient bien et j'ai jamais eu de
réponse ce qui m'étonne c'est que la
Commission y compris des finances
y compris de la commission sociale
depuis le temps que je dis que il y a 3
milliards sans qui sont indûment mis sur
les mesures d'accompagnement qui de fait
alors après vous les laisse plus qu'à 3
milliards personne ce soir penché sur ça
que font ces 3 milliards moi j'estime en
début de cette réunion que nous avons la
démarche de manœuvre pour 3 milliards
sont de mesure d'atténuation de la
brutalité de votre de votre
réforme alors effectivement on peut être
que pour nous l'aurions proposé très
d'ailleurs je l'avais dit
très très naturellement mais nous
n'avons pas
si chers collègues madame Lubin pour
explication de votre
oui monsieur le ministre moi j'ai
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai je reprends
un des arguments que j'avais développé
avant-hier je crois pourquoi ne mettons
pas à profit ce projet de loi puisque
vous cherchez combien de le dire ma
collègue atténuée certains nombres
d'effets
des conséquences qu'il aura pour faire
en sorte que toutes les personnes qui
sont qualifiées de personnes handicapées
puissent avoir un droit de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans certaines restent à 62
en fonction
[Musique]
soit on est en âge soit on est en
incapacité je ne sais pas très bien je
n'arrive pas à comprendre d'autant que
ces personnes-là ne travaillent pas et
bénéficient d'autres sources de revenus
qui sont prises sur d'autres chapitres
budgétaires de nos comptes de la
sécurité sociale
si chers collègues docteur Chasson pour
explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre monsieur du
ministre de la prison mes chers
collègues donc moi je suis bien sûr tout
à fait d'accord avec cet amendement
c'est une avancée importante pour les
personnes qui ont travaillé dans un
secteur de pénibilité puisque passer de
d'incapacité de 20% à 10% de d'accident
après maladie professionnelle ou
accident de travail pour avoir leur
retraite à 60 ans c'est quand même une
amélioration très importante pour nos
concitoyens comme une exposition qui
passe de 17 ans à 5 ans donc je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
bien pour nos concitoyens je pense qu'il
faut le dire
certains disent que il y a beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui regardent cette CDA
et bien là on peut dire que c'est une
avancée sociale importante et aussi
elle a une réparation des dommages subis
par les assurés exposés à la BD
pénibilité au cours de leur carrière
puisque il y a un maintien à 60 ans de
l'âge minimum de départ de retraite
anticipée pour incapacité permanente
donc je pense que il faut féliciter donc
leur rapporteur et des rapporteurs qui
ont mis en place cet amendement et
j'espère que le gouvernement même pourra
donner satisfaction merci
merci Madame Goulet pour explication de
vote
monsieur les ministres moi je veux très
évidemment cette amendement avec
enthousiasme je remercie d'ailleurs les
rapporteurs au nom de la commission de
l'avoir déposé et je voudrais dire au
ministre qu'il fasse confiance au Sénat
parce que vous voyez que sur tous ces
bancs nous sommes nous sommes d'accord
avec cet amendement et que par ailleurs
l'aspect financier n'a pas été relevé
puisque vous pouvez aussi faire
confiance à la commission des finances
pour stopper l'article 40 quand on en a
besoin donc je pense que c'est un très
bon amendement que c'est un très bon
signal aussi les collègues l'ont dit et
donc nous voterons cet amendement
merci chers collègues monsieur rénal
pour explication de vote
plus qu'une explication de vote encore
que je le mets dans ce évidemment dans
la dedans c'est une explication du
président de la commission des finances
sur le fait que on regarde maintenant et
on travaille sur un amendement
clairement article 40
et comment le président de la commission
des finances peut-il laisser passer un
amendement partie 40 et d'autres ont dit
mais nos amendements sont pas passés
alors je voudrais d'abord remercier le
ministre Attal
parce que si il n'y a pas d'Artic 40
aujourd'hui sur cet amendement c'est
parce que le ministre ratal dans ça des
G a ouvert dans des propos
légèrement ambigus mais permettant
d'ouvrir il a dit qu'il ouvrait qu'il
pensait qu'il y avait un intérêt pour
une discussion sur ce point sans
cependant prendre une position
d'ouverture formelle sur ce sujet je
vous rappelle que pour pouvoir dépasser
l'Artic 40 il faut qu'il y ait une
intention du gouvernement est-ce que ça
c'était une intention du gouvernement
les juristes pourraient s'en emparer on
va le dire comme ça mais étant interrogé
sur ce point j'ai souhaité aider la
commission pour donner un avis de
recevabilité alors que
le propos du ministrateur n'engageait
pas formellement le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs on le voit puisque le
gouvernement prend une position
défavorable donc ne couvre pas la
demande donc je remercie vous pouvez
remercier mille sur la table deuxième
point
vous pouvez remercier à ce stade le
ministre au bon parce que il pourrait à
tout moment se lever et dire article 40
on retire il ne le fait pas donc
profitons de ce moment de grâce pour
essayer de voter cette amendement
merci monsieur le Président je donne la
parole maintenant à notre collègue
monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues donc c'est
un amendement qui va dans le bon sens
faut le dire par contre que je
qualifierais pas de avancer social ou de
conquête sociale pour des millions de
travailleurs on est loin quand même de
la philosophie d'Ambroise Croizat parce
que je vais revenir sur les chiffres
les départs anticipés pour les accidents
du travail ou les maladies
professionnelles qui entraînent une
incapacité permanente aujourd'hui dans
le texte et vous l'avez reconnu monsieur
le ministre combien de personnes 3000
3000 personnes chaque année et si on est
élargit tous les critères dont je ne
suis pas sûr et c'est pour ça que je
pose la question à monsieur le
rapporteur ça pourrait concerner au
maximum 20 000 personnes voilà de quoi
nous parlons c'est très bien et nous
allons prendre et nous allons le voter
mais lorsque on vient avant-hier de
voter le recul de l'âge légal de 62 à 64
ans pour des millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses et que on a un tout petit
pas pour au maximum 20 000 travailleurs
et travailleuses je mets un bémol sur
grande conquête sociale vous m'en
excuserez et puis après on a une
deuxième chose
faut en venir sur les critères
pénibilités qui vont permettre encore
d'élargir il y en a quatre qui ont été
enlevés est-ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord d'avoir le débat entre nous
exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux enlever depuis 2017 est-ce
qu'on le rajoute
manutention manuelle de charge est-ce
qu'on continue à l'enlever ou on le
rajoute
posture pénible et vibrations mécanique
c'est les deux derniers est-ce que on
maintient qu'on continue à exclure où on
le rajoute parce que ça ça permet
d'élargir l'assiette vous voyez
peut-être potentiellement de monter à 40
000 personnes donc évidemment pour cela
on va le voter mais en fait on est très
loin je vous le dis celui monsieur le
rapporteur d'une grande conquête sociale
ce matin merci chers collègues madame
poumerol
oui merci madame la Présidente
effectivement depuis des jours nous
insistons sur la perte de quatre
critères de pénibilité qui a été décidé
par Monsieur Macron en 2017 et c'est
vrai que je dirais que cet amendement va
certes dans le bon sens mais moi je ne
targnerai je ne taxerai pas d'avancer
social mais plutôt de non recul par
rapport à ce qui était prévu dans le
texte je pense que effectivement il faut
s'entendre sur les critères et comment
ils vont être inclus de nouveau pour
pouvoir élargir l'assiette parce que
combien vient de le dire mon collègue
Fabien gay cette mesure ne va toucher
que très peu
d'agents et que donc il faut être
vigilant et pouvoir essayer d'élargir au
maximum l'assiette il va toutefois
monsieur salarié dans le bon sens et
nous sommes et nous le voterons donc
avec plaisir
pour précision madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues juste une
petite précision budgétaire et je vous
prie de
m'excuser monsieur le président de la
commission des finances en fait juste
une précision c'était l'élément là ne
portait pas à utiliser l'article 40
pourquoi parce que nous sommes dans
finalement dans ce qui existe dans le
périmètre d'aujourd'hui donc en réalité
vous n'aviez pas opposé les
recevabilités par l'article 40 c'est
plutôt pour un sujet qui qui va suivre
c'est la retraite progressive donc je
voulais le préciser en réalité cette
proposition nous l'avons faite parce que
justement nous pensons que pour un
certain nombre de public les choses sont
difficiles le travail est difficile et
que leur demander cet effort n'était pas
concevable donc je remercie l'ensemble
des collègues qui se sont exprimés pour
dire qu'effectivement eux aussi ils
considéraient que c'était finalement une
mesure de solidarité dans ce projet qui
est difficile on le sait bien passer à
de 62 à 64 ans voilà tout le monde le
dit
ça fait pas l'unanimité c'est clair mais
justement pour ce public en difficulté
nous avons souhaité maintenir et nous
vous invitons à voter cet amendement
alors avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre
je vous informe que 11 sous amendements
viennent d'être déposés sur l'amendement
numéro 21 38 alors que les explications
de vote avaient déjà commencé monsieur
le ministre je vous donne la parole
merci madame la Présidente simplement de
mots d'abord pour dire au Président
carotique si ma fonction me permettait
de donner des haies favorables à tous
les amendements déposés y compris quand
je peux considérer qu'ils ont un intérêt
sur le fond alors qu'il contreviennent à
une recherche d'équilibre budgétaire et
quand bien même ça se passe en dehors
des systèmes du Borne des systèmes de
retraite ma vie serait certainement plus
agréable qu'elle ne l'est parfois quand
je suis au bon ceci étant dit je sais
bien que cette amendement présente un
certain nombre d'intérêts et que nous
pouvons en discuter de manière
extrêmement sereine quand on est sur cet
amendement 21 38 de Monsieur Savary
malgré tout je tiens à répéter deux
choses d'abord une première chose que je
ne répète pas mais que je dis en réponse
au président rénal pour dire que le
gouvernement a lui-même était
circonspect en matière d'articles 40 et
d'appuyer sur la déclaration que vous
avez mentionné la deuxième chose pour
dire que le rapporteur tout à l'heure a
dit à raison que la durée d'exposition
tout comme la question la question
relative à la Commission pluridisc
partenaires relevé du champ
réglementaire mais le sujet est très
sérieux donc je vais éviter l'expression
fromage ou dessert fromage et dessert
mais ça y ressemble un petit peu et si
par voie réglementaire le gouvernement
m'était en œuvre les assouplissements
auxquels nous avons pensé en plus de
cette adoption le coup n'en serait que
renchérit et ça fait partie des choses
qui ne sont pas forcément agréables ceci
étant le gouvernement est à la fois
respectueux et soucieux qui sont
respectés le vote de la commission des
affaires sociales et l'expression d'un
avis défavorable n'empêche évidemment
pas le Sénat de se prononcer sur cet
amendement et de faire valoir sa
position nous verrons ensuite dans le
cas de la commission mixte paritaire si
les choses prospèrent aussi elles ne
prospère pas le gouvernement souhaite
donc le Sénat puisse se prononcer sur un
certain nombre de dispositions et
j'apprends madame la Présidente par
votre intervention que des sous
amendements ont été déposés sur cet
amendement 21-38 je n'ai pas à dire si
le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il y
a des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaite en que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fonds et celui-ci en étant en
application de l'article 44 à neutre de
la Constitution nous considérons et le
gouvernement considère que tout
amendement ou sous amendement déposé sur
cette amendement 21 38 et n'ayant pas
été examinés par la pas été examinée par
la commission sans y recevables
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
conformément à l'article 4 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution à l'article 46 bis
alinéa du règlement le gouvernement
s'oppose à l'examen des sous-amendements
à l'amendement numéro 21 38 qui n'ont
pas été antérieurement soumis à la
commission madame la Présidente de
commission confirmez-vous que c'est sous
amendement n'ont pas été soumis
antérieurement à la commission avant
l'ouverture du débat je le confirme
madame la Présidente merci dans ces
conditions c'est sous amendement ne
peuvent être examinés
je mets donc alors nous avons un rappel
plusieurs rappels au règlement madame
Rossignol madame Rossignol rappelle aux
règlements
je vous en prie
nous allons écouter les rappels aux
règlements
non mais madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre ça vous a pas suffi hier
soir vous avez aimé ça ou quoi c'est
votre vous avez une petite une petite
addiction
identique votre rappel au règlement s'il
vous plaît allez-y madame la Présidente
si défilent pendant que vous parlez à ma
place je prendrai la suite monsieur le
ministre une addiction au rappel au
règlement 12 amendements là vous
déclenchez
ce vote va les recevabilité sa maman
pour 12 amendements mais autant parfois
je peux tout en contestant et le
combattant imaginez en me mettant votre
place pourquoi vous le faites quand il y
en a un grand nombre mais pour 12 si
c'est pas nous priver du débat sur les
sujets sérieux comment et puis comment
ça va finir cette affaire là si à 12
vous vous énervez dites-le franchement
vous voulez pas débattre avec nous
comment elle s'appelle madame Cohen pour
rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente au nom du
44 bis écoutez hier il y a eu des
rappels au règlement du fait des
procédures que vous avez déclenchées
aujourd'hui pour 12 amendements 12
amendements qui étaient extrêmement
important parce que enfin dans cette
émission on allait parler des métiers et
de la vie des gens et de la pénibilité
et puis moi je m'étonne d'une chose
c'est que madame la Présidente de la
Commission se lève en disant que la
commission par exemple appelle en
priorité telle ou tel amendement on sait
pas réunis après on nous dit que comme
ça les sous amendements n'ont pas été
examinés par la commission ils sont
rejetés mais réunis chez nous et on va
on va on va on va décider à ensemble
collectivement avec une majorité enfin
c'est extraordinaire de parler au nom de
la commission quand elle ne se réunit
pas la commission c'est la Présidente
c'est le rapporteur c'est qui la
commission
pour rappel au règlement monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
pas le faire mais je vais le faire ouais
ouais non mais attendez attendez
pas de provocation on est dans le
règlement
ce matin on a demandé une demande de
priorité et je voulais m'exprimer mais
comme c'est un amendement important je
pensais qu'il fallait le débat comme
nous tout et tout aussi mais à un moment
donné le règlement il est pas fait pour
régler une question politique je voulais
déjà dit mais pour organiser notre vie
commune donc quand on est au banc ici en
bas là moi je l'ai jamais été mais quand
on est au banc on est rapporteur on est
rapporteur de la commission on entend
bien rapporteur de la commission pas
d'un groupe politique même majoritaire
de la commission donc je lis bien
article 44-7
ou tirer 6 pardonnez-moi les demandes de
priorité ou de réserve dont les faits en
cas d'adoption ou de modifier lors de
discussion des articles d'un texte ou
des amendements comme ça a été fait ce
matin
lorsqu'elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond par la
commission ni par la présidente ni par
le rapporteur par la commission donc moi
je demande une question je vous pose
quand c'est que la Commission a été
c'est réuni pour délibérer sur la
demande de priorité c'est une question
là là c'est l'utilisation du règlement
n'ont pas régler une question politique
mais pour l'organisation de nos débats
parce que si nous crions comme nous le
faisons depuis deux jours beaucoup
beaucoup de nouveautés alors là je vous
le dis ça laissera des traces dans les
prochaines débats dans les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois voilà non
mais tranquillement et de façon apaisée
donc quand c'est que la Commission a
pris la commission après dans la
Commission comme vous êtes majoritaire
il y a un vote et donc pas de problème
la demande de priorité sera acceptée par
l'ensemble de notre assemblée je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
les choses avaient bien commencé
[Musique]
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
on redescend sur terre on se met à la
portée effectivement de nos concitoyens
qui nous demandent des réponses d'accord
très bien ça fait combien de jours que
j'ai passé cet amendement à la
commission combien de jours ça fait
28 Février 28 février depuis le 28
février est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que quelque part quand on mène une
réflexion approfondie on a quand même le
temps par rapport aux propositions
faites par la Commission de ce retourner
de faire en sorte de faire même des
auditions j'ai refait moins de auditions
par ma part je suis sûr que vous en avez
fait donc vous pouviez effectivement
m'alerter pour que on puisse prenne pour
que l'on puisse prendre les décisions
nécessaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'estime mais peut-être esthor
que les sous amendements qui sont
déposés dans la précipitation sans qu'il
y ait d'études d'impact ne se relève pas
de la commission me semble-t-il il
relève d'une réflexion que nous aurions
pu ensemble enrichir à travers des
réunions de commission tranquille dans
la sérénité nous mettons éventuellement
des auditions supplémentaires qui
auraient fait que le Sénat aurait pu
faire son travail et rentrer de façon
plus
spécifique dans le texte voilà ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me semble qu'un
amendement comme celui-là qui est
largement partagé largement partagé vous
l'avez dit sur tous les bancs méritent
pas franchement d'être à travers ce
texte modifié quelque part vous vous en
seriez rendu compte s'il avait fallu le
modifier avant en conséquence quand tout
le monde sait exprimé il me semble tout
à fait naturel que nous passions au vote
merci
pour Monsieur canard pour rappel
aux règles merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre tout d'abord un
petit mot par rapport à un rappel au
règlement qui a été porté par Monsieur
Olivier et nous hier tardivement dans un
état d'utilisation
assez particulier mais je tiens lui dire
que mon mal-être il est tout à fait bien
surmonté monsieur et nous et que nos
groupes de gauche sont parfaitement unis
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose chez
vous il m'a bien semblé au groupe usé je
ferme la parenthèse
c'était sur l'article 46 bis madame la
Présidente
mais dans le règlement il y a aussi les
attaques personnelles qui sont évoquées
sur le 46 bis moi j'ai une question à
poser à la droite sénatoriale et à la
droite à l'hygiène
c'est une question c'est combien combien
de sous amendements vous nous permettez
en générosité partagée de déposer sur ce
texte
si vous nous dites trois bandes on
déposera 3 5 8
mais c'est un droit nous avons le droit
mes chers collègues de déposer des sous
amendements ça peut être dérangeant pour
vous mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
premièrement premièrement deuxièmement
deuxièmement effectivement monsieur
ministre c'est la deuxième fois que vous
utilisez le 44.2 pour bloquer nos débats
mais c'est une forme de j'ai envie de
d'armes nucléaire tactique
vous avez une autre arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est utiliser le 44 dans
toute sa globalité et d'utiliser donc le
vote bloqué sur la base des rendements
que vous aurez accepté mais si c'est
cela vous voulez pour arrêter le débat
dites le nous le plus vite possible
comme cela les Français seront pris à
témoin de la manière dont vous gérez le
Parlement monsieur Gontard pour rappel
au règlement
merci merci Madame la madame présidente
monsieur le ministre
certes il y a le droit mais il y a aussi
l'abus de droit quand on s'écarne
l'esprit de la Constitution la décision
du gouvernement me paraît d'ailleurs
largement improvisée elle augure mal des
discussions à venir sur le débat
parlementaire monsieur le ministre je
vous demande solennellement de prendre
les mesures nécessaires dans la journée
pour que le débat ait lieu il n'est pas
bon de soumettre ainsi le Parlement à un
rapport de force inadmissible recourir à
des instruments de rationalisation du
parlementarisme quand l'on dispose d'une
telle majorité constitue à mes yeux un
aveu de faiblesse de la part du
gouvernement nul besoin de recourir à de
tels artifices si l'on dispose
d'arguments convaincants
pardonner la VMA c'est la solennité de
mon propos mais un autre ton ne pouvait
convenir quand le moment est si grave
ce sont les paroles de Philippe Bas
questeur en 2018 sur le texte d'André
Chassaigne pour les retraites agricoles
parce que effectivement le gouvernement
utilisé ce type d'artifice donc je pense
que aujourd'hui on pourrait revenir un
petit peu au sérieux monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas sérieux d'utiliser
et de supprimer une douzaine de sous
amendements sur un amendement
d'importance comme l'a dit monsieur
caoutchi a priori plutôt bien construit
et donc quand je continuerons continuons
justement à le construire pour notre
part notre groupe on avait un sous
amendement on est quand même très très
loin de l'obstruction on était pour
ajouter pour discuter pour améliorer
améliorer cette amendement donc je pense
que là franchement on avait
effectivement bien débuté dans les
quelques minutes de notre de notre débat
ce matin je pensais que la nuit avait
été bonne pour chacun je pense qu'il
faut redescendre ben voilà je pense
qu'il faut peut-être revenir de la
sérénité on a il nous reste à peu près
un peu moins de 1000 amendements
travaillons sur ces oui travaillons sur
ces amendements travaillant sur ses
amendements avançons et tout ira bien
merci alors j'ai encore deux rappels au
règlement monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez prendre la parole avant
merci madame la Présidente quelques mots
d'abord nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps avec madame la Présidente
rossignols et même si nous avons un
désaccord sur ce texte et peut-être sur
d'autres je pense que madame la
Présidente me demandait
ce qui m'a donné du plaisir hier soir ou
pas
et d'addiction je pense madame la
Présidente que si j'avais utilisé le
même vocabulaire pour vous interpeller
vous m'en auriez fait rire
donc vraiment vraiment madame la
Présidente je pense que vous me l'auriez
reproché et peut-être que d'ailleurs
vous auriez eu raison de le faire mais
je ne le fais pas à votre à votre
endroit je sens simplement je pense
qu'on peut éviter ce genre de
vocabulaire la deuxième chose pour
répondre au président Kanner chez le
Président vous avez le droit de déposer
des sous amendements de la même manière
ton application de cet article 44-2 le
gouvernement a le droit de s'opposer à
l'examen de l'ensemble des
sous-amendements déposés sur un
amendement ou un article dès lors qu'ils
n'ont pas été examinés par la commission
préalablement
deuxième troisième point pardonnez-moi
troisième point sur l'intérêt
l'opportunité la pertinence de d'évoquer
d'avoir recours aux 44 de en l'état il y
a deux choses qui m'ont amené à le faire
la première c'est que j'ai en tête un
passage du débat d'hier un débat initié
par le président le contraire sur une
liste monsieur le Président de 140
amendements 45-40 sous amendements que
vous aviez déposé demandant que soit
consulter
telle caisse de retraite telle organisme
de conseil 140 amendements
beaucoup d'entre vous ont une grande
expérience parlementaire et nous savons
tous que lorsqu'on commence à écrire
notamment dans un amendement ou un sous
amendement en général on perd en
lisibilité ou en évidence et la plupart
des amendements en tout cas pour ceux
que j'ai vu commence par notamment et
vise à ajouter à l'amendement du
rapporteur des professions pour dire en
cas d'incapacité permanente notamment
pour par exemple nous avons le sous
amendement
numéro et que je ne dise pas de bêtises
972 qui dit notamment pour les moniteurs
d'école de conduite il y a certainement
un travail et une discussion à voir sur
leurs conditions de travail mais je
pense que nous pouvons ainsi décliner
sous amendements autant qu'il y a de
profession deuxième exemple
un amendement insoum amendement numéro
967 qui dit notamment pour les
professeurs des écoles et là celui-ci
m'a encore plus interpellé et en tout
cas à mes yeux il relève d'une volonté
d'obstruction la retraite pour
incapacité permanente ne concerne pas
les agents publics
et on a la des sous amendements qui
viennent sur des professions publiques
qui partent nocturnes sont pas
concernées par le dispositif proposé par
le rapporteur quel est l'autre intérêt
que de retarder le moment du vote et le
retarder Paul Senna la capacité de se
prononcer sur le fond à propos d'un
capacité permanente
[Applaudissements]
pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mais mes chers collègues la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
fait qu'il intervient très très peu sur
l'organisation de nos débats très
rarement monsieur le ministre quand le
gouvernement utilise
l'article 41 et l'article 44 2 de la
Constitution vous vous introduisez
directement dans le débat de notre
assemblée et vous donnez par la même la
possibilité aux conseils constitutionnel
de donner un avis sur nos débats en
faisant ça non seulement vous fragilisez
l'article 9 parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel va regarder précisément
dans le détail les modalités de son
adoption et donc va regarder nos débats
mais par ailleurs chers collègues vous
fragilisez aussi la capacité du Sénat à
organiser librement ses débats merci
madame la Présidente
monsieur rénal pour rappel au règlement
non très très court et sur le même
fondement simplement pour dire que le
rapporteur nous a fait une réponse qui
n'était pas la bonne en m'excusant il a
été questionné sur le fonctionnement de
la commission dont il est le rapporteur
donc moi j'attends toujours qu'il nous
réponde sur le fond sur la question moi
je le dis parce que ce qui me gêne dans
cette affaire qui est le fait que la
Commission soit pas réunie est
préalablement alors que c'est alors que
c'est tout bêtement le règlement c'est
que mes chers collègues c'est votre
c'est vous qui avez ouvert ces questions
réglementaires avec l'article 38 je vous
le rappelle c'est vous qui avez ouvert
le sujet d'un strict respect strict
respect des règles de fonctionnement et
bien si un strict respect que ce respect
est lieu et que les choses se fassent à
l'avenir correctement et donc on a vu
aujourd'hui une façon de faire c'est
fait voilà et à l'avenir faisons les
choses déjà correctement dans l'ordre
c'est tout réglementaire pas plus
merci Madame à la présidente rappelle au
règlement article 44 2
mes chers collègues depuis
presque 10 jours le mot principal c'est
débats vous voulez le débat et vous
regrettez que le débat n'est pas lieu
mais vous voulez une forme particulière
de débat vous voulez le débat sans fin
c'est une stratégie c'est la stratégie
de la paralysie vous avez transformé ces
travées en tranchées c'est votre choix
néanmoins quelle est la mission d'un
parlement ce n'est pas seulement de
parlementer c'est aussi de légiférer
légiférer c'est-à-dire délibéré voter
décider ce n'est pas votre but
malheureusement
et en choisissant la stratégie de la
paralysie
inconsciemment ou involontairement vous
nourrissez vous renforcer le vent
mauvais de l'antiparlementarisme
vous renforcez
les sirènes du populisme mes chers amis
attention aux boomerang
monsieur carochi
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente de Monsieur le
Ministre on avait bien démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements
sincèrement si ça c'est pas de
l'obstruction je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle si vous aviez tant d'idées
pour sous-amander cette amendement qui a
été adopté par la commission le 28
février c'était il y a 12 jours pendant
12 jours silence radio et puis d'un coup
une masse d'amendement de sous
amendement qui tombe ce qui veut dire
très clairement que votre intention
c'est de ne pas aller au bout du débat
votre intention c'est à chaque
amendement de déposer des sous
amendements c'est de l'obstruction
presque caricaturale à partir de là la
décision du gouvernement d'appliquer le
44 2e est tout à fait normal et légitime
vous l'avez je vous rassure quand vous
étiez au gouvernement largement utilisé
beaucoup utilisé dois-je vous rappeler
que par exemple la réforme Touraine a
été adoptée en deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale par un vote bloqué
un vote bloqué un vote bloqué par un
détail un vote bloqué donc je pense qu'à
la matière il faut rester assez serein
dire que si on veut aller au bout du
texte il faut que chacun y mette du sien
pardon monsieur le Président Kanner
j'étais je le reconnais un peu choqué de
votre part parce que je vous estime
beaucoup mais
être en photo entrain de manger le
règlement du Sénat pardon de vous dire
ce n'est pas digne de notre assemblée
madame Lubin pour rappel au règlement
non pas Madame Lebas pardon
madame brûlin pardon excusez-moi madame
brûle pour rappel au règlement monsieur
gay je ne vous donnerai pas la parole
une deuxième fois pour rappel au
règlement il y a madame apportsopoly qui
prendra la parole
non non monsieur carotine a fait une
explication de votre tout à l'heure
c'était pas une deuxième rappel au
règlement madame Brulin pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente nous
assistons à une utilisation me
semble-t-il abusive
de la priorité appelée sur certains
amendements qui ne tient plus à assurer
la clarté de nos débats mais qui devient
une arme de destruction massive de
sous-amendement lesquels sous
amendements viennent sous cette forme
parce que un certain nombre de nos
amendements on n'y va pas y revenir mais
c'est important de le rappeler ont été
déclarés y recevables pour des raisons
qui restent tout à fait obscures voilà
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui
il n'y a même plus
d'arguments réglementaire
sur l'annulation de ces sous amendements
il n'est plus question que de chiffres
tantôt 140 que ça peut faire tomber et
maintenant on en est arrivé à 12 faire
tomber 12 vous ne ferez croire à
personne que vous allez accélérer le
débat en faisant ça parce qu'à chaque
fois que vous utilisez ces procédures
nous le retardons
régulièrement vous le retarder
non
c'est un nom
c'est un nom collectif c'est un nom
c'est un oncle c'est un nous collectif
collectivement collectivement par vos
procédures ce débat est retardé enfin il
n'a pas été répondu à la question qui a
posé Fabien gay quand la commission
s'est-elle réunie pour demander cette
priorité va-t-elle le faire et va-t-elle
faire son travail puisque parce que nous
ne pouvons pas admettre que des sous
amendements soient rejetés au motif
qu'ils étaient dans la même veine que
des précédents ou qu'ils n'ont pas été
posés pendant les 12 derniers jours mais
vous savez qu'il s'est passé des choses
c'est 12 derniers jours vous savez ce
qui se passe dans le pays depuis cette
douze derniers jours et bien notre débat
doit
chers collègues
donc oui il y a des choses
pour un rappel au règlement
oui merci même ma présidente alors je
veux rappeler effectivement que nous
défendons cet amendement seulement moi
j'ai pas encore perçu pourquoi il a été
mis prioritaire il pouvait très bien
être défendu dans sa place donc la
commission effectivement nous a jamais
informé que quel que soit quelque soit
le moment où on reprendra la discussion
à la commission elle aurait pu dire
celui-là on le mettra prioritaire on
vous informe ce qui aurait quand même
permis que ça soit une décision de la
Commission plutôt qu'une décision
simplement du rapporteur
moi monsieur le ministre je suis quand
même étonné vous empêchez donc ces 12
amendements d'être défendus mais vous
les commentez ça c'est quand même
incroyable en malhonnêteté
intellectuelle c'est à dire on a deux
amendements vous dites ils ne seront pas
discutés et vous prenez la parole pour
dire en quoi ils sont ridicules en quoi
ils vous semblent en quoi il vous semble
44 10 on se calme donc je veux dire il y
a vraiment souvent parce que moi je peux
je comprends pas l'intention de la
priorité de cet amendement et puis là
aussi vous continuez vous parlez de nos
intentions c'est bien vous lisez mais la
tension en droit je veux dire c'est très
difficile
même pour la faute grave il faut prouver
l'attention de nuire et je sais que pour
la faute lourde pardon et que les
employeurs ils renoncent parce que
l'intention à la prouvé c'est quand même
très très difficile alors effectivement
vous avez pas voulu prendre le temps de
ces 12 amendements c'est ce lac disait
ma collègue communiste regardez nous les
aurions défendus le temps qu'on proteste
qu'on trouve aux méthodes prendra plus
de temps que la défense de nos 12
amendements
[Applaudissements]
oui madame la Présidente mon rappel au
règlement s'appuie sur
l'article 13 du chapitre 6 de notre
règlement et les articles suivants
relatifs à l'organisation des travaux
des commissions c'est quand même
extrêmement surpris mais chers collègues
que il n'est pas été répandu ni même
tenté de répondre
dans une approche éloignée à la question
de savoir en quoi la commission des
affaires sociales
pouvaient se préoccuper de la
recevabilité de certains amendements
est-ce une décision solitaire de notre
collègue présidente de commission ou du
rapporteur ou est-ce une décision
collégiale vous voyez j'ai eu le
l'honneur pendant trois ans avant mon
collègue rénal de présider la commission
des finances qui est avec la commission
des affaires sociales celle qui a
examiné qui a à examiner des textes
financiers et qui par ailleurs par
tradition depuis maintenant un certain
nombre d'années et confiait un élu d'un
groupe d'opposition et quand on est dans
cette position politique ça oblige à une
certaine modestie c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut quand même très
prudemment observé ce qui relève de
l'espace de décision personnelle du
président par exemple la censure au
titre de l'article 40 dénominations
individuelles que sais-je et ce qui
relève du travail collectif de la
Commission et encore faut-il pour que ce
travail collectif puisse se dérouler
qu'elle se réunissent donc je repose la
question de savoir quand notre
commission des affaires sociales a eu à
examiner la recevabilité d'un certain
nombre d'amendement
lors des
examens de loi de finances nous
réunissons la commission des finances le
matin avant la séance parfois assez tôt
de façon à pouvoir balayer tout un tas
d'examens qui ont été déposés dans la
nuit je ne vois pas en quoi la
commission des affaires sociales ne
pourrait pas faire un travail de même
nature
Madame A pour ce Boli pour explication
pour rappel au règlement pardon merci en
vertu donc de l'article 44 bis nous
évoquons ici 12 amendements 12
amendements monsieur le ministre que
vous avez caricaturé parce que vous avez
oublié de dire que dans ces dans ces
sous amendements nous évoquons les
sages-femmes les infirmiers psy les
puéricultrices bon voilà hein alors oui
la commission s'est réunie monsieur
Savary et vous l'avez dit
une la fois passée au mois de février
pour dire que votre amendement était
recevable on n'a pas de souci sur ça
mais pourquoi est-il mis en priorité
avec ma collègue Laurence Cohen et
d'autres d'ailleurs nous participons aux
commissions des affaires sociales nous
sommes présentes à la commission des
affaires sociales on peut pas dire le
contraire mes collègues vous ne pouvez
pas dire ici sur les bancs qu'avec
Laurence Cohen et mes collègues de
gauche et vous d'ailleurs nous ne soyons
pas attentif à cette commission des
affaires sociales nous y sommes à toute
pratiquement
à toutes non mais ça serait de mauvaise
foi que vous nous disiez ça parce que
nous sommes présentes en commission des
affaires sociales et nous y participons
merci merci de redire madame douanouano
qu'effectivement nous sommes présents
que vous l'avez pas dit merci madame
douanot de reconnaître que nous sommes
présentes à ces commissions des affaires
sociales alors alors
je reviens pourquoi est-ce que le
rapporteur avec la présidente décide de
nous faire passer pour des pantins et de
ne pas réunir à nouveau cette commission
des affaires sociales et pourquoi est-ce
que vous décidez à deux trois ici sur
les bancs de la majorité sénatorial de
ne pas nous réunir
monsieur kerouge pour rappel au
règlement
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
bis Repetti ta place Sainte nous avons
prévenu et vous recommencez la même
perspective que celle que vous avez
lancée là hier soir c'est très très bien
c'est sur la base du 46 2 du règlement
pour que tout le monde soit soit à
l'aise alors plusieurs points puisque
certains nous donnent des cours sur ce
que devrait être le Parlement j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour répondre sans
acrimonie aucune à notre collègue
Hainaut qui nous a interpellé hier
Patrick Tanner et moi-même pour lui dire
d'une part que c'est très certes
confortable mais on ne choisit pas son
opposition et que effectivement nous
sommes à gauche déterminés contre cette
réforme et ensuite j'ai entendu
également monsieur Paco nous faire un
cours sur ce que devrait être le
Parlement alors et je le dis avec
modestie d'ailleurs j'invite à Monsieur
Hainaut à les parcourir s'il le souhaite
j'ai une petite expérience en la matière
et petite bibliographie qu'il peut
éventuellement consulter sur ce sujet
précisément le Parlement le Parlement
n'est pas
une espèce d'enceinte administrative
dans laquelle il faut prendre
automatiquement des décisions un
parlement c'est aussi la traduction des
rapports de force dans une société c'est
aussi simple que ça et en l'espèce vous
tentez de brider ses rapports de force
alors ne vous étonnez pas ne vous
étonnez pas de la situation que vous
avez vous-même créé je l'ai dit hier je
le répète donc vous livrerez à ce petit
jeu nous ferons exactement le même le
débat n'avance pas c'est un choix
manifestement que vous souhaitez
conforter il est ridicule nous ne
pouvons pas avancer continuons
écoutez monsieur Pacaud vos jugements
n'engagent que vous mais les Français
les Français voient le ridicule de la
situation et on vous remercie
le président Laurent pour un rappel aux
règlements
merci madame la Présidente
c'est abus des procédures réglementaires
juste pour rigoler un peu il paraît que
l'imprimerie ici est en rupture de stock
parce que tout le monde apprend par
coeur le règlement du Sénat voilà où on
en est arrivé mais je voudrais faire un
commentaire sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue
ponce à propos de l'intervention du
ministre parce que non seulement la
Commission ne prend visiblement pas la
peine de réunir la commission des
affaires sociales pour examiner le
problème de la recevabilité des
amendements mais semble-t-il si j'en
crois les commentaires du ministre la
liste des amendements qui sont
déclarésor recevables et faites sous la
dictée du ministre et ça c'est
extrêmement grave
parce que et pour cette raison je veux
le redire au poids où nous en sommes et
vu l'usage répété de cette
irrecevabilité la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales après
une suspension de séance devient
absolument indispensable sinon ça veut
dire que cette liste d'amendements
irrecevable serait dans les couloirs
entre le ministre et la présidence de la
Commission et les rapporteurs c'est à la
Commission d'examiner cette question et
pas au ministre de venir nous commenter
des amendements qui ne seront même pas
soumis au débat
merci président
enfin pour un deuxième rappel au
règlement monsieur gay mais j'espère que
ça ne fera pas jurisprudence il a il en
a le droit et ensuite je mets au vote
règlement quel article mais
oui mais ce que vient de dire le
président Laurent attendez on vous
propose ensemble
une sortie de crise non mais
je relis
je relis parce que vous nous répondez
pas ni le rapporteur ni le ministre
lorsque demander par la Commission
saisie au fond sur la question de
modifier l'ordre de discussion d'un
article ou des amendements je le dis
parce qu'il y a madame la Présidente
prima et donc si je mens elle le dira
lorsque ça nous est arrivé depuis 5 ans
d'avoir des demandes de priorité soit on
l'a évoqué en commission
soit c'est vrai et président en caoutchi
l'a dit elle a eu
normale elle a prévenu l'ensemble des
chefs de fil par groupe politique pour
dire je demanderai sur tel ou tel
amendement de le placer en priorité vrai
ou pas madame la Présidente vous le
savez on ne l'a jamais découvert en
séance publique ce que vous êtes en
train de faire depuis hier on demandant
des priorités sans réunir la commission
n'est pas acceptable et ce qu'a dit le
président Laurent est extrêmement
important c'est la séparation entre
l'exécutif et le Parlement ce n'est pas
au ministre de décider si tel ou tel
amendement ou sous-amendement est
valable ou pas c'est à la commission qui
fait le tri si la commission se réunit
en 5 minutes et décide ensemble que les
sous amendements ne sont pas recevables
alors nous l'accepterons mais nous ne
pouvons pas tripatouiller le règlement
comme cela nous sommes en train de créer
des précédents extrêmement dangereux
qu'ici demain
c'est un pouvoir autoritaire ou
fascisant il aura toutes les armes parce
qu'ici il n'y a que des républicains
démocrates dans cette missile mais il
aura tous les pouvoirs pour annuler en
réalité le pouvoir des sénatrices et des
sénateurs et de notre assemblée faisons
attention ne trie pas toujours pas le
règlement comme ça nous arrange
réunissant la Commission en 5 minutes
chez la faire
[Applaudissements]
je mets donc au vois cet amendement avec
un avis défavorable du gouvernement qui
vote pour
je mets aux voix l'amendement qui vote
pour
qui vote contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté monsieur le ministre
merci merci madame la Présidente je
souhaitais madame présente intervenir
mais juste un mot de réaction et le
sénateur game n'en prendra pas ombrage
j'en suis sûr c'est le sénateur vous
dites que je déciderai de ce qui est de
recevoir en réalité pour être tout à
fait précis l'article 44 2 de la
Constitution n'autorise pas le
gouvernement à dire si tu en amendement
il recevable ou il recevable c'est la
prérogative de la commission par contre
l'article 44 2 autorise le gouvernement
à refuser l'examen de sous amendement et
d'amendements qui n'ont pas été examinés
préalablement par la commission ça n'est
pas une appréciation sur la recevabilité
c'est une procédure constitutionnelle
qui m'autorise aujourd'hui comme membre
du gouvernement a refusé que ce soit
soumis à l'examen des articles qui n'ont
pas fait l'objet d'une adoption
ceci étant ceci étant madame
ceci étant madame la Présidente ceci
étant madame la Présidente je sollicite
de votre bienveillance une suspension de
séance de 15 minutes
je suspends la séance donc pour
que tout à l'heure
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
et voilà le Sénat qui vient de mon cœur
de suspendre la séance dans cet examen
de la réforme des retraites après des
débats où le ce matin et de nouvelles
tensions entre la gauche sénatoriale et
la droite Sénart sénatoriale et
également le gouvernement alors
peut-être pour rappeler ce qui s'est
passé ce matin on va retrouver Quentin
calmé dans la tribune de l'hémicycle
Quentin expliquez-nous ce qui s'est
passé il y a eu et bien beaucoup de
tensions autour de sous amendements
déposés par la gauche mais qui ont été
rejetés par le gouvernement exactement
alors effectivement on était sur
l'article 9 on parlait pénibilité on
avait commencé à discuter à 9h45 quand
on n'aura pas parlé très très longtemps
pénibilité un 10h15 on a vu que et bien
ça c'était embrasé de nouveau dans
l'hémicycle on voit ses débats qui sont
très tendus maintenant depuis trois
jours que s'est-il passé exactement la
commission de l'affaire sociale avait
demandé à ce qu'on examine un de ses
amendements en priorité ça ça lui est
permis par le Règlement du Sénat donc
son amendement monte tout en haut de la
liste
puisque il y a une rumeur qui brise sur
un possible utilisation une possibilité
d'un autre article de la Constitution
dans les minutes voire dans les heures
qui viennent de l'article 44 alinéa 3
sur le vote bloqué Alexandre merci
Quentin et on va en parler avec notre
invité sur ce plateau pendant cette
suspension de séance Roger carottechi
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains premier vice-président du
Sénat un mot sur ces nouvelles tensions
ce matin entre la droite sénatoriale et
la gauche sénatoriale on a l'impression
qu'on va avoir du mal à aller au bout de
cette réforme des retraites au Sénat
clairement la gauche ne veut pas de vote
clairement elle le dit d'ailleurs depuis
le début on a eu tout ce qu'il fallait
des centaines de sous amendements
déposés nuits à des rappels au règlement
incessants des explications de vote qui
n'en finissait pas des amendements
identiques déposés à l'infini bon
clairement la gauche ne veut pas voter
je considère que c'est un tort c'est un
tort pas seulement pour la gauche quelle
droite s'exprimer et qui s'exprime
d'ailleurs largement elle a utilisée
plus de 90% du temps de débat depuis 8
jours mais le Sénat est fait pour voter
l'Assemblée nationale est faite pour
voter on n'est pas fait pour discuter à
l'infini du sexe des anges ou être des
groupes de parole nous sommes là pour
faire la loi et nous avons d'ailleurs
voté un certain nombre d'amendements
quand même ces derniers jours qui sont
des apports sur les carrières longues
sur l'emploi des seniors sur
l'invalidité on a fait le boulot mais
maintenant on voit bien que la gauche va
à nouveau bloquer on dit
les sous amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés sur l'amendement priorité
l'amendement était adopté le 28 février
ils sont déposés là à la dernière minute
c'est clairement de dire voilà on va
vous en déposer 12 là l'amendement
suivant vous en déposera 15 et puis 20
et puis 30 bon clairement il y a pas de
vote possible si c'est comme ça je le
regrette infiniment parce que ça veut
dire que le gouvernement qui a déjà mis
en place l'article 44.2 qui permet
d'écarter les amendements qui n'ont pas
été discutés par la commission risque de
dire si nous voulons un vote il faut
finir par le vote bloqué et ce serait
l'utilisation de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution je le regrette infiniment
parce que je suis un défense acharné du
Parlement mais quand on bloque
complètement le Parlement de manière
irresponsable et bien il faut attendre
s'attendre à ce qui est des conséquences
franchement la situation hallucinante je
n'ai jamais vu ça en 20 ans le Sénat est
là pour délibérer sereinement pour faire
le travail pour améliorer les textes la
situation de blocage est un sens le
gouvernement qui pourrait utiliser ce
vote bloqué sur cette réforme des
retraites au Sénat rappelez-nous
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
signifierait si le gouvernement dit al
enfin article 44 Linéa 3 ça veut dire
qu'il fait voter de manière bloquée en
un seul vote sur les articles en
acceptant seulement les amendements que
le gouvernement accepte c'est-à-dire pas
les amendements votés par le Sénat mais
seulement les amendements que lui
accepte ce qui est quand même une
réduction forte du pouvoir du Parlement
mais je rappelle que pour la loi
Touraine pendant le gouvernement
socialiste en 2013 le gouvernement
socialiste avait fait le vote bloqué
pour la deuxième lecture de la réforme
Touraine à l'Assemblée nationale donc
effectivement malheureusement c'est une
pratique possible pour écarter le débat
parlementaire et le fait que la gauche
fasse de l'obstruction conduit à cela
donc selon vous le gouvernement
le choix de maîtriser
que le blocage continue que la gauche
continue ce blocage et il ne peut pas y
avoir de vote dimanche soir
soit la gauche dit bon allez stop on
arrête tout on fait un vrai débat
jusqu'à dimanche soir et on va au vote
et là ça peut se passer sereinement si
ça n'est pas le cas si le gouvernement
veut un vote et bien naturellement il
passera par le 44.3 ce que dit la gauche
sénatoriale c'est que le droit
d'amendement des sénateurs et un peu
piétiné par la droite sénatoriale c'est
un droit d'amendement constitutionnel et
que est-ce que ça peut fragiliser et
bien cette réforme de retraite sur la le
constitutionnelle parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel apprécie en premier lieu
les tentatives de blocage et lorsqu'il y
a blocage lorsqu'il y a effectivement
une tentative d'empêcher le Parlement de
voter le Conseil constitutionnel en
prend vraiment compte et là quand tu
verras la masse de rappel au règlement
la masse de la mandement identique les
centaines de sous abonnements déposés
une nuit d'Amand le Conseil
constitutionnel dire il y avait
obstruction et par conséquent les moyens
du règlement ou de la institution devait
être mise en place ce que disent les
sénateurs de gauche c'est que ce n'est
pas normal que la Commission refuse
d'examiner certains amendements qui sont
déposés non mais si vous déposez à tout
moment dans la nuit ou après l'ouverture
de la discussion générale des
sous-amandes plus déposer amendement des
sous-amendements clairement la
Commission peut pas suivre et donc ça
n'est qu'une tentative d'empêcher le
débat donc dans ces conditions
malheureusement je ne sais pas comment
ça va se passer si le gouvernement
n'utilise pas d'autres armes je doute
que l'on arrive au vote sauf si la
gauche se ressaisissant disait nous nous
voulons vraiment dans les trois jours
qui viennent débattre sur un certain
nombre d'amendements forts pour nous
auquel cas la discussion est possible et
si c'est pas le cas et si c'est juste
pour faire multiplier des rappels au
règlement des sous amendements et tout
autant dire que le Sénat ne fait pas son
travail René Paul Savary a parlé hier
soir d'un accord qu'il y avait entre les
présidents de groupe à droite et à
gauche pour aller au bout de cette
réforme des retraites je n'en sais rien
moi je n'étais pas dans cette réunion
mais clairement on a été extrêmement
gentleman si je puis dire à l'égard des
groupes de gauche sur ce qu'ils ont
demandé pour le 7 mars sur l'article 7
et tout visiblement ça ne sert pas à
grand chose la confrontation est
malheureusement devenue la règle au
Sénat ce qui n'était pas l'habitude une
dernière question Roger carotic sur le
fond quand même de ce qui a été discuté
ce matin il y avait plutôt un accord
entre les sénateurs de gauche et les
sénateurs de droite pour voter un
amendement sur les travailleurs déclarés
en incapacité permanente et pour qu'il
puisse partir à 60 ans à la retraite
c'est dommage que les débats ait tourné
vinaigre bah oui moi j'ai des fendu je
me suis levé pour défendre cet
amendement et demander au gouvernement
de ne pas s'y opposer parce que ça me
paraît essentiel c'est ça le rôle du
Sénat c'est d'apporter des améliorations
c'est de penser aux gens pas seulement
aux rivalités politiciennes
malheureusement
avant même le vote de cet amendement on
a sombré dans les rivalités merci
beaucoup merci à carochi d'être venu sur
le plateau de Public Sénat pendant cette
suspension de séance on va retrouver
Quentin calmé en tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat Quentin faites-nous vivre un
peu c'est tension cette matinée de
nouveau électrique juste un mot
Alexandre pour vous dire que la rumeur
de l'utilisation dans l'article 44 3 de
la Constitution se fait de plus en plus
pressante d'après les sources de Public
Sénat effectivement il y a maintenant et
bien 45 minutes on a entendu le
gouvernement utilisé un article de la
Constitution écouter le ministre du
Travail
j'apprends madame la Présidente par
votre intervention que des sous
amendements ont été déposés sur cet
amendement 21 38 je n'ai pas à dire si
le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il a
des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaite en que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fond et celui-ci en étant en application
de l'article 44 à la constitution nous
considérons et le gouvernement considère
que totalement ou sous amendement déposé
sur cette amendement 21 38 et n'ayant
pas été examinés par la pas été examinée
par la commission sans y recevable
on peut le dire et qui a enflammé les
débats ce matin Alexandre pourquoi parce
que le déclenchement de cette procédure
par le gouvernement fait tomber des
facto des sous amendements qui avaient
été déposés par la gauche sénatoriale la
gauche ce matériel qui est bien dénonce
le fait qu'elle ne puisse pas défendre
ses amendements sur le fond qui se
plaint d'être censuré en quelque sorte
par cette procédure on a vu par exemple
le président du groupe socialiste réagir
écoutez-le nous avons le droit mes chers
collègues de déposer des sous
amendements ça peut être dérangeant pour
vous mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
vous avez une autre arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est utiliser le 44 dans
toute sa globalité et d'utiliser donc le
vote bloqué sur la base des rendements
que vous aurez accepté mais si c'est
cela vous voulez pour arrêter le débat
dites le nous le plus vite possible
comme cela les Français seront pris à
témoin de la manière dont vous gérez le
Parlement voilà Patrick canin qui évoque
la menace de l'utilisation de l'article
44 3 le vote bloqué qui permet au
gouvernement d'utiliser uniquement les
amendements qu'ils de de pardon
d'examiner uniquement les amendements
qu'il choisit et bien d'après les
informations dont nous disposons cette
ce recours à l'Artic 44 3 de la
Constitution serait imminent dans
l'hémicycle à la reprise de 11h05 un
dernier mot pour vous dire que de son
côté la droite sénatoriale assume de
voilà vouloir faire tomber sous
amendement de la gauche écouter Olivier
Pacaud
vous voulez le débat sans fin c'est une
stratégie c'est la stratégie de la
paralysie vous avez transformé ces
travées en tranchées c'est votre choix
néanmoins quelle est la mission d'un
parlement ce n'est pas seulement de
parlementer c'est aussi de légiférer
légiférer c'est à dire délibérer voter
décider ce n'est pas votre but
malheureusement et en choisissant la
stratégie de la paralysie inconsciemment
ou involontairement vous nourrissez vous
renforcer le vent mauvais de
l'antiparlementarisme voilà il est 11h01
Alexandre la séance est programmée pour
reprendre à 11h05 on verra ce qui se
passe à ce moment-là et s'il y a un
déclenchement de l'article 44 à Linéa de
la Constitution merci beaucoup Quentin
et pour parler de cette matinée
électrique au Sénat accueille sur ce
plateau Laurence Cohen bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice communiste du Val-de-Marne une
réaction à ce qui se passe ce matin le
gouvernement qui utilise un article de
la Constitution pour rejeter des sous
amendements de la gauche qui ont été
déposés un petit peu dans la
précipitation sur un amendement du
rapporteur du texte et ce qu'il y a
quand même une volonté d'obstruction de
la gauche équatoriale et de ralentir le
plus possible les débats pour éviter un
vote finale sur cette réforme le
problème c'est que en fait on est
empêché de débattre par la droite qui
est parfaite complexité complicité avec
le gouvernement et avec le ministre
Olivier du soft parce que les sous
amendements que nous avons déposé elle
concerne la vie des gens les conditions
de travail des sages-femmes des
infirmiers des infirmières et on les a
déposés ils sont parfaitement bien
ficelés si je puis dire puisque ils font
partie d'un amendement qui avait été
rejeté sous des prétextes fallacieux
déjà donc c'est un vrai travail que nous
avons fait donc un problème de de la
droite du gouvernement de refuser le
débat de fond parce qu'ils veulent faire
passer cette loi qui est rejetée par la
majorité des Français
la première chose est la deuxième chose
quand même je suis membre de la
commission des affaires sociales je suis
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales et aujourd'hui au banc
de la commission il y en a deux qui
décident la présidence et le rapporteur
mais la commission ça n'est pas deux
personnes qu'ils réunissent la
commission des affaires sociales comme
c'est c'est même pas d'usage comme le
règlement le stipule pour qu'on prenne
une décision ils ont la majorité de
toute façon leur déshydrateur sera voté
mais au moins que nous puissions
échanger aujourd'hui là finalement on se
retrouve avec une présidente et un
rapporteur qui ne sont plus la
présidente elle est plus responsable
représentante et oui responsable de la
commission des affaires sociales elle
est responsable d'un groupe politique le
groupe LR le groupe majoritaire donc ça
ne va pas ça sert à quoi d'être membre
de la commission et de travailler
ensemble quand au moment du débat dans
l'hémicycle finalement c'est une ou deux
personnes qui prennent la décision avec
le ministre parce que la suspension la
d'un quart d'heure on les voit ils sont
il y a des conciliabules partout donc il
y a on bafoue enfin on Bafou pas nous
mais en tout cas le groupe majoritaire
et le ministre Bafou la démocratie dans
cet enceinte et c'est eux qui piétinent
le parlementarisme alors le gouvernement
pourrait je parle bien aux conditionnel
pourraient utiliser aujourd'hui
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
pour bloquer le vote du Sénat sur cette
réforme des retraites c'est-à-dire aller
seulement sur des amendements qui sont
choisis par le gouvernement et puis
voter sur l'ensemble du texte ce serait
un coût très dur porté aux droits du
Parlement écoutez c'est un coup
supplémentaire mais ça commence déjà
depuis hier avec des priorités qui sont
accordées à un certain nombre
d'amendements donc il y a déjà un tri
des amendements depuis depuis hier donc
là ce serait un une étape franchie
supplémentaire mais je pense qu'en tout
cas ça démontre que ce que je viens de
vous dire et plus que la réalité et
qu'il y a un refus de débattre du fond
parce que ils veulent passer en vitesse
et peut-être aussi qu'il y a une peur de
voir une très forte mobilisation encore
demain parce que les gens
majoritairement rejettent cette réforme
et on est nous au niveau de la gauche au
niveau du groupe communiste les portes
voies de tous ceux et toutes celles qui
rejettent cette réforme parce qu'elle
est mauvaise mais est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même l'objectif de la
gauche et sénatoriale d'éviter un vote
finale sur l'ensemble du texte la gauche
veut absolument parler du fond ce que
refuse la droite et ce que refuse le
gouvernement donc le but c'est
effectivement d'aller au fond des choses
sur chaque amendement quand on est
arrivé avant l'article 7 il nous dit oh
là là il faut absolument arriver très
vite à l'article 7 quand on est arrivé à
l'article 7 qui lui recule l'âge de
départ à la retraite il a fallu bâcler
les choses et puis on continue on est
sur la pénibilité il faut encore aller à
toute vitesse donc finalement le thème
pot il est donné par le côté
vraiment autoritaire de la droite et du
gouvernement de faire passer les choses
en force nous on a notre le rythme une
autre rythme c'est le rythme de la
gauche mais c'est aussi le rythme des
gens qui disent stop à cette réforme
est-ce que dit le gouvernement est aussi
la droite sénatoriale dans ce débat
c'est que quand on lit les dizaines
d'amendements et de sous amendements qui
sont déposés par la gauche et bien en
fait vous jouez sur une déclinaison de
métier de produits chimiques par exemple
notamment sur la pénibilité et s'il n'y
a pas justement un jeu pour rallonger le
temps de débat ou est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment aller sur un débat sur sur
chaque métier mais écoutez c'est très
important de parler des métiers parce
que ça montre la pénibilité des métiers
et ça fait entrer la vie des gens dans
l'hémicycle parce que on en parle peu
des gens dès qu'on donne des exemples
précis où il y a des huées au niveau des
travées de la droite donc voilà ils sont
obnubilés en disant le Sénat va pas
voter cette réforme bah si on la vaut
pas et ben tant pis pour eux et tant
mieux pour pour les gens qui verront que
dans les hémicycles et bien il y a un
certain nombre de parlementaires qui
sont à leur côté et qui sont pour que la
forme ne passe pas peut-être un mot sur
le fond une dernière question Laurence
Cohen il y avait un accord ce matin
entre les sénateurs de droite et les
sénateurs de gauche pour permettre aux
travailleurs qui sont déclarés en
incapacité permanente et bien de pouvoir
toujours partir à 60 ans c'est dommage
que le débat est mal tourné finalement
bah oui mais c'est de la faute à qui
c'est de la faute à la droite qui est
fait tout pour crisper les choses s'ils
avaient laissé l'examen de nos 12
amendements on les aurait déjà terminé
depuis longtemps au lieu de ça il serait
10 il ne respecte pas le règlement donc
on fait des rappels au règlement merci
beaucoup Laurence Cohen d'avoir réagi
assez débats ce matin au Sénat sur la
réforme des retraites donc réaction sur
le plateau de Public Sénat merci
beaucoup on va retrouver Quentin calmer
en tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat
Quentin on le disait un des débats très
tendus et une bataille réglementaire
entre la gauche et la droite qui
continue et Alex je vous ferai remarquer
une séance qui ne reprend pas alors
qu'elle était suspendue pour 15 minutes
elle devait reprendre à 11h 5 mais et
bien il est maintenant 11h08 et la
séance n'a pas repris que se passe que
se passe-t-il dans les coulisses du
Palais du Luxembourg il y a-t-il des
tractations en cours ou effectivement
quelque chose qui est en train de se
jouer c'est ce que l'on verra à la
reprise mais effectivement on examinait
un amendement qui faisait à peu près
consciencieux ça on peut le dire sur un
dispositif de retraite anticipé pour
incapacité pour les victimes d'une
maladie professionnelle avec un droit à
la retraite des 60 ans ce dispositif
était en train d'être discuté puis c'est
là que le gouvernement a déclenché
l'article 44 2 de la Constitution cet
article 44.2 qui permet au gouvernement
de demander à suppression le fait qu'on
examine pas des sous amendements qui
n'ont pas été eux-mêmes validé par la
commission écoutez ce qu'on a pensé
Laurence Rossignol c'est-à-dire dans les
mystique là
monsieur le ministre ça vous a
pas c'est votre vous avez une petite une
petite addiction
identique votre rappel au règlement s'il
vous plaît allez-y madame la Présidente
si défilent pendant que vous parlez à ma
place je prendrai la suite monsieur le
ministre une addiction au rappel au
règlement 12 amendements là vous
déclenchez
ce vote va les recevabilité sa maman
pour 12 amendements
à la séance de hier soir car il y a eu
le même processus l'article 42 44 2
pardon qui a déjà été utilisé hier soir
sur les bancs de la commission c'est
René Paul Savary qui a répondu à la
gauche sénatoriale écouter le
les choses avaient bien commencé
[Musique]
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
on redescend sur terre on se met à la
portée effectivement de nos concitoyens
qui nous demandent des réponses j'estime
mais peut-être échor que les
sous-amendements qui sont déposés dans
la précipitation sans qu'il y ait
d'étude d'impact ne se relève pas de la
commission me semble-t-il voilà on a vu
donc des échanges très musclés et des
tensions vivent entre la droite et la
gauche sénatoriale Alexandre merci
beaucoup Quentin effectivement la séance
qui ne reprend pas sur cette réforme des
retraites dans l'hémicycle du Sénat ça
veut dire que les différents
responsables de la commission des
groupes politiques sont en train de
discuter notamment avec le gouvernement
sur la suite de ces débats au Sénat et
la question qui se pose c'est à Vaton
vers un blocage du vote et du débat au
Sénat par le gouvernement le
gouvernement en a les moyens avec
l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
pour en parler j'accueille sur ce
plateau Vincent et Blais bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
Seine-et-Marne vice-président de la
commission des finances un mot sur ce
qui s'est passé ce matin et même depuis
hier soir ce qui a changé c'est que le
gouvernement lui aussi maintenant veut
accélérer les débats et utilise des
outils constitutionnels pour rejeter
certains amendements de la gauche oui
c'est tout à fait juste et cela se fait
de façon coordonnée avec la majorité de
droite du Sénat puisqu'en fait
d'un côté lorsque nous imaginons des
amendements ou des sous amendements
destinés à répondre à une priorisation
de l'examen des amendements décidés en
séance on ne réunit pas la commission
des affaires sociales qui pourraient
donner un avis sur ses amendements et
par ailleurs le gouvernement refuse
l'examen des amendements qui n'ont pas
été examinés par la commission et donc
en fait on censure le travail
parlementaire et le travail que pourrait
souhaiter les élus d'opposition dont
c'est parti de façon aller au fond de ce
débat qui concerne nos concitoyens on le
voit chaque jour avec les mouvements
sociaux les manifestations et
l'expression du hostilité de l'opinion
française à cette réforme donc pour
contourner cette réalité aujourd'hui on
utilise des artifices de procédure on ne
réunit pas la commission pour examiner
les amendements et mettre des avis le
gouvernement refuse que puisse être
débattue des amendements qui n'ont pas
fait l'objet d'un examen en commission
et donc la boucle est bouclée et en
quelque sorte on va aller vers une forme
de censure encore plus explicite un 49-3
qui ne dit pas son nom puisque ici au
Sénat il ne porte pas ce nom mais enfin
c'est à peu près la même chose
c'est-à-dire la capacité pour le
gouvernement d'exiger un vote global à
votre bloqué qui ne permettent pas le
travail parlementaire tout ça dans un
cadre qui est celui du choix qu'a fait
le gouvernement
de l'examen de cette réforme dans un
cadre de textes budgétaire sécurité
sociale qui normes le temps disponible
pour travailler alors que nous pourrions
parfaitement comme nous le faisons
chaque année ancien président de la
commission des finances j'en ai
l'expérience travailler durablement de
nombreux jours sur plusieurs semaines de
façon apaisée pour aller au fond de
l'examen d'un texte qui est quand même
très compliqué et qui concerne
éminemment nos concitoyens et qui va
leur coûter deux années de vie alors je
le disais la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que le gouvernement va utiliser
l'article 44-3 de la Constitution
aujourd'hui pour bloquer le vote le
débat de cette réforme des retraites au
Sénat et ne sélectionner que certains
amendements Roger carotier a rappelé que
et bien le gouvernement socialiste au
moment du débat sur la réforme des
retraites Touraine en 2013 avait aussi
utilisé le vote bloqué à l'Assemblée
nationale en deuxième lecture de cette
réforme des retraites finalement est-ce
que ce n'est pas de bonne guerre quand
une majorité estime que l'opposition
fait l'obstruction oui mais enfin il
faut quand même laisser au débat
parlementaire la possibilité de se
développer aujourd'hui on nous interdit
d'examiner nos amendements en commission
et ensuite en séance on vient nous dire
que comme ils n'ont pas été examinés en
commission on ne peut pas les examiner
dans l'hémicycle non plus donc il y a
une question une forme de censure qui ne
dit pas son nom mais qui est tout à fait
réel que nous ressentons physiquement
voilà moi j'ai moi-même déposé des
amendements qui ne parviennent pas à
franchir le seuil de l'hémicycle de
façon à être débattue et après on vient
nous reprocher que finalement nous ne
sommes pas sur le débat de fond mais que
nous sommes sur un débat de procédure
mais on nous y contraint voilà donc il y
a un jeu de rôle dans cette affaire qui
n'est pas à la gloire du Parlement ici
au Sénat chacun sait où sont les
majorités d'autant qu'on a une
convergence explicite entre les
sénateurs qui soutiennent la majorité
présidentielle et ce de la droite
sénatoriale qui déjà à eux seuls sont
majoritaires donc je dirais globalement
on sait très bien quels sont les
rapports de force mais malgré ces
rapports de force tout à fait
caractérisés on vient malmener
l'opposition de gauche du Sénat de façon
à lui interdire en quelque sorte de
prendre la parole sur le fond en
refusant l'examen de nos amendements qui
portent au fond de façon à éviter sans
doute que l'opinion française puisse
constater je dirais l'État les forces en
présence sur ces différents sujets merci
beaucoup Vincent ayblet pour votre
réaction on va retrouver Quentin Calmet
dans la tribune de l'hémicycle Quentin
avec une séance qui ne reprend toujours
pas exactement Alexandre ça ne vous a
pas échappé ça fait 10 minutes que la
séance devrait avoir repris puisqu'elle
avait été suspendue pour 15 minutes mais
elle est sur le point de reprendre c'est
imminent puisque on voit que au plateau
ici qui est l'équivalent du perchoir à
l'Assemblée nationale le plateau au
Sénat on voit que tout le monde se met
en place pour la reprise de la séance le
président la présidente de sens qui va
pouvoir par cette porte et se
réinstaller et que va-t-il se passer à
cette reprise c'est toute la question
va-t-il y avoir le déclenchement de
l'article 44 années à trois de la
Constitution qui viendrait contraindre
un peu plus les débats au Sénat c'est la
rumeur qui brûle depuis maintenant
plusieurs minutes que s'est-il passé
avant cette cette suspension de séance
on a vu une forte tension entre la
droite et la gauche sénatoriale on a
même entendu le vice-président LR du
Sénat sermonner un peu la gauche
natariale écoutez Roger carotc on avait
bien démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements votre
intention c'est à chaque amendement de
déposer des sous amendements c'est de
l'obstruction presque caricaturale à
partir de là la décision du gouvernement
d'appliquer le 44 2 et tout à fait
normal et légitime voilà la science qui
va reprendre dans l'instant à l'autre
Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin Xavier question simple est-ce
que le gouvernement doit raccourcir ses
débats et utiliser l'article à 43 de la
Constitution pour bloquer le vote du
Sénat sur cette réforme des retraites et
aller et bien directement aux votes sur
l'ensemble avec des amendements
sélectionnés par le gouvernement je
voudrais déjà rappeler à ceux qui nous
écoutent que nous sommes à 8 jours huit
jours de débat complet jour et nuit qui
nous ont permis d'aboutir à l'article à
l'article 8 là nous sommes à l'article 8
et donc nous allons l'article 9 à
l'article 9 pardon
et donc nous avons un certain nombre de
progrès nous avons pu voter nous avons
pu débattre largement sur sur les les
articles les plus importants et donc
nous avions effectivement un certain
nombre d'articles encore à voir sur les
mesures sociales les 6 milliards de
mesures sociales que le gouvernement a
proposé dans son texte initial des
avancées d'ailleurs que le Sénat avec la
commission des affaires sociales ont
proposé également donc on ne peut pas
laisser dire aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement a muselé le Parlement et
que le Parlement n'a pas pu s'exprimer
preuve en est encore une fois nous
sommes au 8ème jour il y a eu des
procédures d'accélération deuxième jour
très exact deuxième jour vous voyez je
m'y perd donc nous avons eu des
procédures d'accélération effectivement
nous permettant à la fois de ne pas
avoir de des amendements d'obstruction
des sous amendements d'obstructions
comme nous avons pu l'avoir depuis 9
jours et de pouvoir travailler sur le
fond sur les articles de fond et sur les
amendements de fonds qui ont encore une
fois parfois été adoptés à l'unanimité
donc on voit bien que quand on parle de
fond on arrive à trouver un accord au
Sénat après moi je souhaite
effectivement qu'on puisse aboutir parce
que nous sommes des parlementaires et le
rôle d'un parlementaire c'est de pouvoir
voter c'est bien sûr de débattre c'est
d'amender c'est d'améliorer les textes
mais c'est avant tout aussi de voter la
loi et si nous ne votons pas la loi nous
ne servons à rien et donc moi c'est ce
que je dis aujourd'hui au groupe
d'opposition et au groupe de gauche
c'est avant tout de respecter le mandat
qui est qui est le leur c'est à dire de
pouvoir voter les lois personne ne les
oblige à voter pour ils y a des
divergences entre nous et il faut les
assumer mais au moins qu'ils assument le
fait de voter et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
les le mouvement syndical demandent même
la rue la rue ne demande pas de ou le
mouvement syndical ne demande pas de
bloquer il demande de voter contre qu'il
respecte qu'il n'est pas qu'il n'est pas
l'oreille sélective et puis qu'ils
écoutent effectivement ce pourquoi ils
ont été élus c'est-à-dire voter les lois
je le rappelle ils avaient accovelli
vous êtes Center du groupe RDPI au Sénat
c'est le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que vous avez des
informations est-ce que vous savez si le
gouvernement va utiliser cet article 44
alinéa 3 de la Constitution pour bloquer
le vote moi je n'ai pas d'information et
même si j'en avais je vous le donnerai
pas avant que le gouvernement s'exprime
ce n'est pas mon rôle moi je il y a des
outils de la Constitution qui n'ont
jamais été remis en question par les
différents gouvernements successifs donc
la Constitution donne effectivement
confère à la fois des droits au
Parlement et des droits au gouvernement
pour s'assurer que les débats puissent
se dérouler correctement et que nous
puissions avoir des lois qui soient
voter in chinées moi je souhaite
effectuer le gouvernement utilise ce
vote moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
d'ici dimanche nous puissions avoir une
réforme des retraites qui soit votée
amender préparer et qu'on puisse engager
la commission mixte paritaire avec
l'Assemblée nationale à partir de
mercredi matin dans de bonnes conditions
parce que quel signal désastreux si ni
l'Assemblée nationale ni le Sénat ne se
serait prononcé sur sur ce texte donc
oui moi je souhaite que nous puissions
accélérer les débats pour pouvoir voter
ce texte alors la droite sénatoriale et
le gouvernement veulent accélérer les
débats mais quand on regarde un peu où
on en est on est vendredi on est à
l'article 9 il reste mais un peu moins
de 1000 amendements enfin on est en
retard
on n'est pas en retard parce que nous
avons mis un certain nombre de
procédures notamment le 44 2 qui je
rappelle est dénoncé aujourd'hui par le
groupe socialiste mais qui avait été
largement utilisé par le groupe par le
gouvernement socialiste à l'époque pour
la réforme des retraites la réforme
Touraine dans le deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale rappeler
d'ailleurs par le vice-président karucci
donc on voit bien que c'est un outil
constitutionnel qui est utilisé par les
différents gouvernements pour nous
permettre d'avancer et principalement
sur la question de la réforme des
retraites parce que quand on fait une
réforme des retraites c'est souvent pour
demander un effort supplémentaire aux
Français et donc le débat doit avoir
lieu nous avons eu nous aurons un cas
quasiment 100 heures de débats au sein
de cette hémicycle je pense que le débat
maintenant doit continuer et nous devons
surtout voter avant dimanche merci
beaucoup à Xavier acovénie d'être venu
sur le plateau Public Sénat direction
l'hémicycle la tribune de l'hémicycle du
Sénat pour retrouver Quentin Quentin
toujours pas de reprise de séances non
et en plus être prise elle crucial et
j’allaise téléspectateurs il faudra
monter le son lorsque la séance va
reprendre car il pourrait y avoir le
déclenchement de l'article 44 alinéa 3
de la Constitution effectivement ce sont
les informations dont dispose Public
Sénat elle a reprises dont on ignore
pour l'heure le moment où elle va avoir
lieu puisque et bien les sources ne
donnent pas plus d'informations pour
l'instant sur l'ordre de la reprise
pourquoi est-ce que c'est crucial est-ce
que ça signifie que et bien en coulisse
sans doute y a-t-il une tractation sur
les amendements ou ou les sous
amendements que le gouvernement pourrait
concerner dans et bien ce qui va se
passer avec le 44 3 le vote bloqué ou le
gouvernement choisi les amendements et
qu'il décide de soumettre au vote au
Sénat on a entendu cette forte tension
depuis une heure dans l'hémicycle entre
la droite naturelle et la gauche
sénatoriale la gauche c'est naturel qui
est bien se plaint d'être bâillonné par
les différents recours à la constitution
au Règlement du Sénat écouter le chef de
fil des écologistes Guillaume Gontard
on avait effectivement bien débuté dans
les quelques minutes de notre de notre
débat ce matin je pensais que la nuit
avait été bonne pour chacun je pense
qu'il faut redescendre ben voilà je
pense qu'il faut peut-être revenir à la
sérénité on a il nous reste à peu près
un peu moins de 1000 amendements
travaillons sur ces oui travaillons sur
ces amendements travaillons sur ses
amendements avançons et tout ira bien
oui Public Sénat donc qui peut et bien
vous dire que à la reprise des travaux
il devrait il pourrait y avoir on va
garder les conditionnel l'utilisation du
44 aliné à trois de la Constitution le
vote bloqué le gouvernement qui peut
choisir ses amendements et les soumettre
au Sénat Alexandre merci beaucoup
Quentin j'accueille sur ce plateau Yann
chanterelle bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste des Français établir
de France si jamais dans quelques
minutes et bien le gouvernement annonce
l'utilisation de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution pour et bien un vote bloqué
sur cette réforme des retraites ce
serait un coup dur pour le Parlement bah
oui
dessus c'est clairement ça elle souhaite
marcher sur les Français aussi qui
manifestent à travers nous puisque nous
nous sommes leur porte-voix ici et donc
nous ne nous laisserons pas faire c'est
ce qu'on essaie c'est ce que je pense à
bien compris la majorité sénatoriale à
chaque fois qu'ils activeront ce taux ce
type de procédé nous ne nous laissons
pas faire nous voulons débattre du fond
nous avons déposé des amendes pas un
grand nombre nous voulons en débattre en
plus c'était pas problématique en fait
le problème principal c'est que la
Commission aurait très bien pu se réunir
pendant 5 10 minutes pour 19 amendements
c'est rapide à juger pour dire ils ne
sont pas recevables n'ont même pas pris
ce temps-là donc en fait il fragilise
même le Parlement à travers leurs
actions vous pensez justement qu'avec
ces manœuvres d'accélération des débats
ici au Sénat de la part de la Commission
de la droite sénatoriale et de
gouvernement ça pourrait fragiliser
constitutionnellement cette réforme des
retraites même si elle était adoptée au
Sénat absolument tous ces artifices qui
sont en train d'être utilisés
fragilisent le texte
déjà on a vu ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale où il a pas pu
l'être au bout si jamais ça ne va pas au
bout qui plus est avec ce genre
d'utilisation d'articles je pense
qu'effectivement le gouvernement
lui-même avec la complicité de la
majorité sénatériale sont à prendre de
prendre un risque en créant des
précédents et en fragilisant le texte
constitutionnellement ou justement
depuis le début ces problématiques c'est
pas faute de le dénoncer on a dit que
c'était problématique d'utiliser
l'article 47 ans dans ce de d'utiliser
le délai contraint pour débattre on a
besoin de temps qu'est-ce qui empêche le
gouvernement de dire très bien nous
avons vu que c'était pas un débat
correct et équitable remettons tout sur
la table reprenant le temps en fait ce
qu'il faudrait faire surtout c'est de se
remettre autour de la table avec l'Inter
cervicale parce qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens pour les écouter pour
essayer d'avoir une une attitude pour
calmer le jeu en quelque sorte
retournons vers la discussion et
reprenons le temps en déposant un texte
qui va permettre de débattre sur la
durée tranquillement comme ça devrait
être fait dans beaucoup débat
parlementaire finalement il y a une
chanterelle est-ce que vous êtes
vraiment surpris par ce qui est en train
de se passer ce matin on entend vraiment
et bien cette possibilité d'un vote
bloqué de la part du gouvernement d'un
côté il y a la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement qui souhaitent un vote
finale sur cette réforme de retraite de
l'autre la gauche rallonge les débats
car son objectif c'est d'empêcher ce
vote final c'est de bonne guerre vous
êtes pas surpris non c'est pas de bonne
guerre parce que comme je vous l'ai dit
tout se passait très bien jusqu'à mardi
soir à partir du moment où la droite a
voulu nous écraser parce que c'est ça
qui s'est passé ce qui nous ont fait
comprendre on dit ce qui est pas correct
ils ont dit on vous a laissé vous a
laissé en de quel droit on peut dire ça
dépend on vous a laissé débattre
jusqu'au le jour des manifestations et à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est fini vous
vous taisez et c'est nous qui décidons
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne et
ça il faut qu'il comprenne à chaque fois
qu'ils font ça qui suppriment des sous
amendements nous continuerons à
l'assemblement à déposer pour que les
sujets qui ne veulent pas débattre
soient quand même débattus parce qu'on
doit ça aux Français qui se battent
contre cette réforme et qui sont très
majoritairement opposé à la réforme et
si jamais le gouvernement dégaine ce 44
3 ce vote bloqué qu'elle pourrait être
la réponse des sénateurs de gauche bah
évidemment nous ne laisserons pas faire
nous interviendrons nous ferons bien
évidemment des appels au règlement pour
pouvoir nous expliquer en quel point
justement cette formule est brutale est
fragilise justement le texte plutôt que
le défendre merci beaucoup Yann
chanterelle et on va suivre et bien
l'évolution de ces débats au Sénat sur
la réforme des retraites des débats qui
sont suspendus ce matin depuis quelques
dizaines de minutes on va retrouver
Quentin calmer dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin on va faire
un retour d'abord avec vous sur cette
matinée très tendue dans la Haute
Assemblée oui tout à fait Alexandra on a
vu ce moment où et bien les débats se
sont tendus ont débatté tranquillement
de la retraite des personnes en
invalidité et ensuite et bien Olivier du
sept a déclenché l'article 44 2 qui
permet de faire tomber des sous
amendements écouter le ministre du
Travail
j'apprends madame la Présidente par
votre intervention que des sous
amendements ont été déposés sur cette
amendement 21-38 je n'ai pas à dire si
le gouvernement regrette ou pas qu'il y
a des potes sous amendements ça serait
porté une appréciation sur leur contenu
ce n'est pas mon rôle par contre le
gouvernement souhaite en que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur des sujets de
fond et celui-ci en étant en application
de l'article 44 à la constitution nous
considérons et le gouvernement considère
que totalement ou sous amendement déposé
sur cette amendement 21 38 et on n'ayant
pas été examinés par la pas été examinée
par la commission sans tirercevable
voilà une procédure déjà utilisée hier
soir en séance c'est ce qui évalue ce
commentaire ironique de Laurence
Rossignol écouter monsieur le ministre
ça vous a pas suffi hier soir vous avez
aimé ça ou quoi c'est votre vous avez
une petite une petite addiction dis donc
votre rappel au règlement s'il vous
plaît allez-y madame la Présidente
si des fils pendant que vous parlez à ma
place
je prendrai la suite monsieur le
ministre c'est une addiction au rappel
au règlement 12 amendements là vous
déclenchez
ce vote les recevabiliser sa maman pour
12 amendements voilà et de son côté la
droite qui assume et qui soutient ce
recours à la constitution au Règlement
du Sénat pour faire avancer les débats
écouter Roger carochi on avait bien
démarré
on se met à peu près d'accord sur un
amendement et au moment des explications
de vote 19 sous amendements votre
intention c'est à chaque amendement de
déposer des sous amendements c'est de
l'obstruction presque caricaturale à
partir de là la décision du gouvernement
d'appliquer le 44.2 est tout à fait
normal et légitime et voilà Alexandre
pour le fil de cette matinée cette
matinée cette qui a vu cette suspension
de séance elle devait reprendre à 11h05
la séance elle n'a toujours pas repris
pourquoi que se passe-t-il on le sera
dans quelques minutes mais d'après les
informations dont dispose Public Sénat
et bien le gouvernement devrait avoir
recours dans les prochaines minutes on
continue à utiliser les conditionnel
même si nos informations sont
concordantes devraient avoir recours à
l'article 44 alinéa 3 le vote bloqué
Alexandre merci beaucoup Quentin et
justement pour en parler on va faire
réagir Olivier Paco bonjour vous êtes
bonjour
attaché au groupe les républicains du
Sénat sénateur de l'Oise est-ce que vous
souhaitez que le gouvernement utilise
aujourd'hui le vote bloqué sur cette
réforme des retraites
j'espère qu'on en arrivera pas là mais
ce que je souhaite c'est que les débats
retrouvent une fluidité qu'ils n'ont pas
il y a une volonté de coagulation pour
prendre un terme sanguin de la part de
nos collègues de gauche sont dans leur
rôle d'opposant mais même s'ils
utilisent des armes qui sont à leur
disposition dans le règlement intérieur
du Sénat on aboutit à une paralysie qui
est quand même navante
alors
nous souhaitons aller au bout c'est à
dire voter dimanche soir ou avant
Dimanche soir effectivement ce texte un
Parlement n'est pas la seule pour
parlementer même si c'est dans le mot on
est là aussi pour légiférer c'est à dire
délibérer voter prendre des décisions et
objectivement la volonté de nos
collègues c'est d'empêcher d'aller
jusqu'au bout donc si il faut
effectivement que le gouvernement
utilise cette méthode pourquoi pas ce
serait navrant et je pense que ce serait
un aveu d'échec un peu pour tout le
monde quand même objectivement alors que
le ministre du Travail fait son entrée
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat ça veut dire
que normalement et bien la séance de
vers devrait reprendre de manière
imminente Olivier du soft vous dites il
y avait un manque de fluidité dans les
débats mais pourtant ce matin les débats
se passaient plutôt bien il y avait
d'ailleurs un accord entre 7H de gauche
et de droite pour permettre ces
travailleurs qui sont déc larés en
incapacité et bien de pouvoir toujours
partir à 60 ans donc finalement rejeter
19 sous amendements de la gauche c'est
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement ce matin
est-ce que justement ça ne rajoute pas
de l'attention
écoutez
l'amendement dont vous parlez du
rapporteur Savary a été voté à
l'unanimité
et cet amendement faisait progresser le
texte justement en prenant en compte le
cas des personnes qui souffrent
d'incapacité à partir de là rajouter 19
sous amendement au dernier moment avec
un unique but gagner du temps jouer la
montre est-ce que c'est responsable non
ce n'est pas responsable je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure dans les débats
malheureusement
nos amis de gauche ont transformé les
travées du Parlement en tranchés ils
sont dans une guerre de tranchées de
résistance de perte de temps ces
passages le Parlement c'est pas ça le
Parlement merci beaucoup Olivier Pacaud
pour votre réaction merci je vous laisse
regagner les miss cycle du Sénat en nous
on va retrouver Quentin Calmet en
tribune Quentin ça y est ça va enfin
reprendre cette on entend la sonnerie
qui résonne dans les couloirs du Palais
du Luxembourg la présidente Nathalie
Delattre qui est en place pour
effectivement prononcer la reprise de la
séance les ministres qui sont au ban la
Commission les représentée donc la
séance va pouvoir reprendre dans
l'instant à l'autre c'est parti retour à
la séance
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
ou des bâtons du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative depuis le 2 mars dernier
dans cette émission votre avant ont
commencé les jours précédents en
commission de très nombreuses
amendements ont été déposés examinés et
les débats ont été nourris
nous avons eu ensemble dans cette
émission 74 heures de débat sur un sujet
central celui de l'avenir de système de
retraite par répartition
à chaque article malgré des discussions
de fond malgré des avancées portées par
la commission bien sûr par plusieurs
groupes nous le regrettons mais
l'obstruction est devenue un choix
méthodique et répété des groupes
d'opposition nous avons eu quelques
illustrations pas plus tard que ce matin
je pense à la déclaration de madame la
sénatrice brûle qui nous dit très
clairement et je la remercie de cette
clarté qu'à chaque fois que nous avons
nous avancerons tous sera mis en oeuvre
pour nous ralentir je pense aux
expressions utilisées hier au sujet du
dépôt des sous amendements qui ont été
présentés comme une vie sans fin et avec
la volonté de faire en sorte que le
nombre de sous-amand déposés soit
toujours plus important pour empêcher le
Sénat de se prononcer dans la clarté sur
l'ensemble du texte et sur les
dispositions de fonds je pense aux
séries d'amendements identiques ou
analogue avec des déclinaisons de
profession avec des déclinaisons
d'institutions à concerter avec des
déclinaisons de dates lorsque les sous
amende non comme seul objet que de
décaler d'un jour puis de deux jours
puis de trois jours puis de quatre jours
la date de remise d'un rapport lui-même
demandé par un parlementaire d'un groupe
d'opposition cela caractérise une
obstruction méthodique et une volonté de
priver le Sénat de sa capacité à
délibérer et à se prononcer dans la
clarté pour dire qui soutient et qui ne
soutient pas les dispositions qui sont
proposées le choix du gouvernement la
ligne du gouvernement la seule qui
vaille à nos yeux et celui de la clarté
des débats pour les sénateurs comme pour
les Français qui me regardent et qui
vous regardent
nous faisons un choix clair nous avons
une volonté claire celui d'éviter de
contourner et de mettre fin à une
obstruction qui est devenue systématique
et qui n'a comme ça l'objectif je le
répète d'empêcher les sénateurs et les
sénatrices de se prononcer sur des
dispositions de ce texte et sur cette
réforme qui est majeure pour l'avenir
des Français
nous aurions pu considérer que le
calendrier parlementaire tel que prévu
par la Constitution la loi organique
serait suffisant nous considérons qu'il
est absolument essentiel que le Sénat
puisse se prononcer sur le fond dans la
clarté que cette clarté des positions
toute respectueuse dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité dans le soutien
comme à l'opposition à ce texte mais que
cette clarté des débats est tout à fait
primordiale pour pouvoir ainsi avancer
et que cette réforme puisse continuer à
être discutée
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente en application de l'article
44 alinéa 3 de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du Règlement du
Sénat le gouvernement demande à votre
assemblée de se prononcer par un vote
unique sur l'ensemble du texte ainsi que
sur les articles 9 à 20 en retenant les
amendements et les sous amendements
suivants je vous ferai la liste dans un
instant mais en précisant que cette
annonce ne remet pas en cause ce qui a
déjà été examiné et adopté à l'article 9
avant la suspension de semences
le gouvernement propose que soit soumis
à sevate unique les amendements pardon
pour les itérations numéro 21 33 21 34
21 41 21 36 modifié par le
sous-amendement 471 21 35 21 37 21 39 21
43 21
44 21 46 21 47 21 48 21 50 et 21 52 à
l'article 9
pour ce qui concerne l'article l'article
10 les amendements 21-54 20 59 rectifier
terre 21 55 20 58 rectifié 20 60
rectifié bis 21 56 21 57 21 58 21 59 et
21 60 pour ce qui concerne les
amendements portant additionnels après
l'article 10 les amendements 22 95 20 24
20 21 61 rectifié bis 45 47
475 rectifié pour les amendements on
interrompt un instant le ministre parce
que il va égrainer une liste
d'amendements pendant les prochaines
minutes mais comme nous vous n'allons à
l'antenne de Public Sénat il y a
quelques minutes le gouvernement en
l'occurrence représenté par Olivier du
socle le ministre de travail qui
déclenche l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le vote bloqué et qui est
donc en train de donner tous les
amendements qu'il souhaite voir voter
dans la réforme des
retraites puisque effectivement cet
article de la Constitution lui permet de
choisir la liste des amendements qu'il
souhaite voir examiner et donc faire
tomber tous les amendements de
l'opposition ou qu'ils ne souhaitent pas
voir examiner et voter par le Sénat
c'est donc si en train de se jouer c'est
une nouvelle étape l'étape majeure dans
l'utilisation de la Constitution ou du
Règlement du Sénat puisque c'est une
c'est une arme très contraignante on
retourne écouter le vie du soft
[Musique]
ou encore qui vont nous permettre de
donner suite à un vote intervenu en
première partie permettant la
modification du niveau
du niveau de l'objectif national de
dépenses en matière d'assurance maladie
autant d'amendements qui permettent
d'améliorer ce texte et qui permet de
poursuivre je tiens à préciser mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous
allons pour ce qui concerne les articles
qui suivent notamment les tableaux
financiers avec mes excuses puisque
j'aurais dû traiter l'article 13 dans la
première série de numéros que j'ai
indiqué le gouvernement propose aussi
donc de retenir les articles les
amendements pardonnez-moi 21 66 21 67 21
69 21 70 21 72 21 73
214 21 75 21 76 21 77 ainsi que les
amendements 23 60 rectifié bis 21 78 21
79 21 80 21 82
article 13 que nous proposons aussi de
retenir pour ce qui sera soumis au vote
unique les amendements 13 69 et 21 83
qui portent article additionnelles après
l'article 13 l'amendement 25 25 50 25 63
pardon rectifié avant l'article 14
l'amendement 47 23 à l'article 14
l'amendement 47 24 à l'article 15 et
l'amendement 2184 à l'article 16
évidemment cette liste vaut exclusion de
tous les autres amendements y compris
des amendements portant articles
additionnels
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc en
application de l'article 44 dernier
alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf du règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
articles 9 à 20 et sur l'ensemble du
texte en ne retenant à partir de
maintenant que les amendements proposés
ou acceptés par le gouvernement sans
remettre en cause les amendements
précédemment
adoptés y compris ceux adopter jusque à
cet article 9 les amendements restants
en discussion retenus par le
gouvernement viennent d'être listés par
le ministre il reçoivent donc en quelque
sorte un avis favorable
si vous me l'autorisez je ne vous
redonnerai pas la liste vous allez avoir
la distribution de cette liste dans
quelques minutes
à l'exclusion donc de tous les autres y
compris des amendements portant articles
additionnels
monsieur le ministre nous avons bien
entendu vos propos il s'agit par le
recours à cette procédure d'assurer la
clarté et la sincérité de nos débats et
de mettre un terme à l'obstruction
mes chers collègues je vous rappelle que
dans le cadre de la procédure de votre
unique les auteurs des amendements
conservent leurs droits de présentation
en conséquence chaque amendement pourra
être soutenu pendant deux minutes et la
Commission et le gouvernement donneront
leur avis il n'y aura en revanche plus
d'explications de vote individuelle sur
chacun des amendements et des articles
je finis de vous expliquer et ensuite
vous ferez des rappels aux règlements
laissez-moi finir vous expliquer et nous
ferons ensuite les rappels au règlement
mais certains souhaitent avoir cette
explication
de même les prises de parole sur
articles sont possibles dans les
conditions fixées par la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents réunis le 8
mars dernier c'est-à-dire à raison de
deux minutes pour un orateur par groupe
à l'issue de la présentation des
amendements nous passerons aux
explications de vote et au vote unique
sur les amendements retenus et sur
l'ensemble du texte
voilà les explications mes chers
collègues je vois quelques rappels aux
règlements monsieur Kanner pour rappel
au règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 44 bis
la mèche est dite mes chers collègues
vous indiquez mes chers collègues que
voilà nous ne sommes pas étonnés
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans mon
rappel le règlement je lui ai dit
j'avais dit à Monsieur mimi mais quand
allez-vous sortir le 44 3
c'est fait c'est fait je vous rappelle
que si on en arrive là c'est parce que
bien évidemment des articles du
Règlement général du Sénat ont été
utilisés que le 47 1 de la Constitution
a été utilisée en amont par le
gouvernement et que la tactique et la
technique de l'amendement prioritaire
rectificatif a été utilisé pour faire
tomber nombre d'amendements de
l'opposition
nous vous donnons acte monsieur le
ministre et Mesdames et Messieurs et
sénateurs et sénatrice de sénatrice et
sénateur de la droite sénatoriale que
vous avez décidé donc avant la grande
journée du 11 mars
de montrer au pays vos réels intentions
que je qualifierais et ne le voyait pas
mal de réactionnaires puisque c'est bien
une réforme réactionnaire dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui une réforme de
régression sociale il restait 1000
amendements à examiner il nous restait
plus de 30 heures de je crois de débats
et donc nous pourrions nous aurions pu
tranquillement montrer aux Français
notre volonté
nous allons nous allons nous allons
rester je vous assure nous serons en
séance pour débattre des amendements que
vous nous tolérez monsieur le ministre
en termes d'examen mais madame la
Présidente pour nous permettre néanmoins
de prendre acte mais aussi de considérer
les conséquences d'une telle décision du
gouvernement je sollicite de votre part
et je crois que ce sera bien légitime
une suspension de séance pour permettre
aux on a trois groupes de faire le point
de la situation
monsieur le Président je vais d'abord
prendre les autres rappels aux
règlements notamment celui de Monsieur
gontin pour rappel au règlement
oui merci merci madame la Présidente sur
l'article 44 bis
quel aveu de faiblesse quel aveugle
faiblesse ouais ouais franchement
je crois que franchement je l'ai dit
beaucoup de fois ces derniers temps mais
là un terrible aveux de à votre
faiblesse oui votre majorité se fissure
ce texte n'a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale et on a vu on a vu les
conditions
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis demandent
demande solennellement être reçue par le
Président de la République qui leur
refuse toujours d'ouvrir la porte et de
et de continuer des discussions
l'ensemble de la population est dans la
rue et attend une réponse et vous voulez
passer en force quelle image vous donnez
c'est d'une brutalité c'est une
aliénation du Parlement c'est tout
simplement honteux honteux
Victor Hugo avait appelé son chien Sénat
et oui le Sénat est devenu le toutou du
gouvernement voilà où on en est voilà où
on en est
alors
la majorité sénatoriales effectivement
voilà oui allez allez oui monsieur
carucci je sais que ça vous embête mais
je continuerai je continueai voilà oui
rappelle aux règlements oui on a pas le
droit de s'adresser quand je parle voilà
ok voilà
donc moi je demande également évidemment
une suspension de séance et les
suspension de séance qui soit
suffisantes parce que vous vous accordez
une suspension de séance le gouvernement
s'accorde une suspension de séance pour
pouvoir réécrire son texte on a quand
même la possibilité de pouvoir réagir et
pouvoir se réunir mais en tout cas moi
je le dis on ne pourra pas continuer à
accepter cette allée nation du du
Parlement et on nous on ne sera pas le
toutou du gouvernement
monsieur le Président Laurent pour
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente nous y sommes voilà
donc le coup de force du gouvernement
que vous prépariez en fait depuis mardi
depuis les appels incessants au recours
à toutes les procédures pour mettre fin
au débat
comme l'a dit à plusieurs reprises la
présidente de notre groupe Eliane
assassy il s'agit effectivement d'un
terrible aveux de faiblesse vous qui
êtes ultra majoritaire au Sénat vous
êtes incapable de faire voter le texte
dans des conditions normales de débat
et tout cela parce que vous avez décidé
parce que vous avez décidé depuis le
premier jour non seulement de faire
voter les 64 ans mais de les faire voter
en acceptant les conditions imposées par
le gouvernement avec le recours aux 47
ans et vous vous êtes mis dans une
situation d'abaissement du Sénat de
jouer le jeu que vous imposez le
gouvernement vous vous êtes condamné au
silence pendant les premiers jours du
débat pour jouer ce jeu puis à partir de
mardi quand vous avez vu que le
mouvement populaire prenait une telle
ampleur vous avez décidé l'obstruction
c'est vous qui avez organisé
l'obstruction depuis mardi pour
finalement justifier ce coup de force du
gouvernement et vous allez donc aller
chers collègues à la CMP mercredi alors
que l'Assemblée nationale n'aura pas
voté le texte et qu'il aura été adopté
ici par en fait ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un 49 sénatorial parce que le
vote bloqué c'est la même chose donc
vous allez aller à la CMP je vous le dis
mes chers collègues de droite nos
cautionnez pas cela parce que vous le
paierez très cher dans le pays parce que
le pays vous regarde ne cautionnez pas
cela
la seule issue possible aujourd'hui
c'est le retrait du texte le retrait du
texte
madame Cohen pour Abel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente comme vient
de le dire mon collègue Pierre Laurent
le 44 3 c'est le 49.3 du Sénat et
franchement le Sénat ne sort pas grandi
par cette nouvelle procédure le
parlementarisme est piétiné par le
gouvernement je dois le dire mais avec
la sentiment de la majorité de droite LR
cent triste et c'est triste c'est triste
pour la démocratie c'est triste pour le
peuple c'est triste pour tous toutes
celles et tous ceux qui qui nous
regardent et franchement pourquoi vous
avez fait ça parce que depuis le début
procédure sur procédure vous avez
souhaité tendre les débats vous allez
vous avez souhaité dramatiser les débats
et vous avez refusé de parler du fond
c'est à dire des conséquences de votre
projet sur la vie des gens c'est ça la
réalité et pourquoi il y a une telle
attitude des droites avec le
gouvernement c'est parce que vont le
projet du gouvernement c'est le frère
jumeau de votre projet mesdames et
messieurs de droite puisque ça fait
quatre ans ça fait 4 ans que René Paul
Savary présente le recul de l'âge de la
retraite donc vous êtes enfin soulagé de
voir cette réforme scélérate votez de
cette manière-là par des parlementaires
qui acceptent que le parlementarisme
soit piétiné c'est pas glorieux c'est
triste mais les conséquences vont être
graves parce que aujourd'hui vous
piétinez l'opposition et demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer alors ne
mettez pas la main sur le cœur en disant
oh le Sénat c'est bien mieux que
qu'ailleurs nous nous sommes respectueux
c'est être respectueux que de bafouer
l'opposition de gauche de la baïonner
bah pour moi c'est anti démocratique et
c'est ce que vous faites et en plus la
commission des affaires sociales a été
piétiné puisque elle n'a jamais été
réunis depuis le début et ça c'est aussi
très grave si Madame Rossignol madame la
Présidente Rossignol pour rappel aux
règlements
merci madame la Présidente pour que tout
le monde à l'extérieur qui cherche à
comprendre qui s'instruit sur la demande
du Sénat comprennent bien qu'elle est la
conséquence de la décision du
gouvernement en accord avec la majorité
sénatoriale à partir de Nore et avant
nous n'allons discuter que les
amendements retenus par le gouvernement
nous serons tout à l'heure quand on nous
aurons pu examiner la liste précise
combien d'amendements de l'opposition
des groupes de gauche ont été retenus
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y en ait
beaucoup ensuite nous allons discuter
des amendements probablement qui ont
convenu au gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale et quand on dit souvent ses
amendements il y aura je le précise un
orateur pour c'est pas nous puisqu'on
présente pas l'amendement le rapport la
commission c'est pas nous puisque nous
ne sommes pas rapporteur et ensuite le
gouvernement ce qui revient à dire que
sur tous les amendements que vous avez
retenus qui ne viennent pas de
l'opposition nous ne pourrons pas
s'exprimer c'est ça la procédure que
vous mettez en place alors vous ne
pouvez pas dire que ce n'est pas une
procédure bâillon vous avez décidé que
la gauche devait se taire jusqu'à la fin
de ce débat et puisqu'on parle de la fin
de ce débat puisqu'on parle de la fin de
ce débat il nous devions siéger jusqu'à
dimanche soir vous avez retenu 70
amendements ça peut aller très vite
visiblement votre intention c'est ça et
très vite et nous ne sommes que vendredi
midi il y avait encore deux journées et
demi complète de travail soit 3 6 8
séances 8 séances alors vous qui voulez
faire travailler des Français deux ans
de plus vous n'êtes pas capable de
travailler trois jours de plus c'est pas
glorieux
[Applaudissements]
tu aimes la présidente Rossignol juste
de vous indiquer que tous les
amendements qui restent jusqu'à la fin
de la discussion seront présentés vous
aurez donc à présenter les amendements
pas
seulement les amandes qui viennent
d'être cités les amendements qui
viennent d'être cités par le ministre
ont reçu un avis favorable mais
l'ensemble des amendements le petit
millier qui reste seront présentés je
donne la parole pour rappel au règlement
au président à Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
tout au long de ces débats on
s'attendait bien à ce que vous vous
opposiez à ce texte et on en a pas été
surpris on avait vu au compteur un
certain nombre d'amendements mais la
question qui était posée c'était de
savoir si vous vouliez que dans le temps
qui était quand même compté plus de 120
heures de débats nous puissions nous
exprimer et voter et plusieurs fois
Roger caoutchi avec calme et pondération
a appelé les débats à progresser à
avancer
c'est étonnant et se demandant s'il y
avait pas une forme d'obstruction au
fond c'est toute la question bien sûr
qui a ce texte des retraites bien sûr
que vous avez le droit de vous y opposer
nous-même parfois on a des réserves sur
le calendrier sur la forme sur la
question du travail sur le sens du
travail et tout ça c'est le rôle du
Parlement mais le Parlement et c'est
même j'irai dire quelque chose qui
dépasse la réforme des retraites le
Parlement la démocratie représentative
elle doit parler débattre mais aussi
s'exprimer et c'est ça qui fait notre
clivage on n'est pas très heureux de
devoir utiliser une procédure comme
celle-là mais pourquoi on fait ça
pourquoi on fait ça
on a parlé de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quelquefois quelquefois je dis qui rôde
mais c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire
c'est pas ça que je vais vous dire c'est
pas ça que je vais vous dire au moins
lui il y a une différence avec vous
c'est qu'il a l'obstruction glorieuse et
vous vous avez l'obstruction honteuse et
c'est ça mes chers collègues qui depuis
le début est une forme d'hypocrisie vous
ne voulez pas vous exprimer mais vous
vous camouflez derrière des arguments de
procédure et cette obstruction honteuse
elle vous grandit pas et nous on veut
aller au bout de ce de ce texte pour le
Sénat pour la démocratie représentative
je vous remercie madame pense et manche
pour rappel au règlement madame
pansement pour rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente qu'est-ce qui
se joue avec ce 44-3 c'est que le
gouvernement la droite devient il
libéral il libéral vous devenez
autoritaire et pourquoi ben tout
simplement parce que vous êtes
extrêmement minoritaire et quand on est
minoritaire qu'on veut imposer son point
de vue on devient inébaral vous avez usé
du triptyque bien connu provoquer
réaction répression vous nous avez
provoqué constamment ce matin quel était
le sens de la priorité de l'article
aucun ce que vous vouliez c'est qu'on
fasse des rappels au règlement donc vous
nous avez provoqué nous avons réagi et
maintenant vous nous réprimer en 68
c'était bien connu ça oui tout à fait
moi
personnellement je tiens à adresser un
message au mouvement social qui est
majoritaire et que le gouvernement
malgré cela
veut passer en force oui mais parce que
j'explique rappelle au règlement madame
ponce non je ne peux pas accepter donc
je donne la parole à Monsieur Fernique
pour un rappel au règlement en attendant
la Présidente chers collègues donc sur
la base de l'article
sur la base sur la base de l'article 42
9 de notre règlement qui dit comment se
passent les choses quand le gouvernement
dégaine le 44 3 de la Constitution je
crois qu'il faut bien qu'on prenne
conscience les autres que si ça se passe
ainsi ça signifie que nous n'aurons plus
qu'un seul vote un sol sur l'ensemble du
texte et sur l'ensemble des amendements
dont on nous a donné oralement une liste
et dont nous attendons de pouvoir
découvrir ce que nous aurons au menu que
nous aurons à avaler d'un seul coup
belle clarté d'elle sincérité des débats
quand il n'y a que les pour qui
s'exprimeront car ça aussi il faut en
prendre conscience un seul vote mais
systématiquement un seul son de cloche
en trois temps en trois temps je le
concède il y a les auteurs de
l'amendement cela ils sont pour leur
amendement en principe
il y a la commission favorable à ses
amendements et il y a le gouvernement
dont j'ai l'impression qu'il sera
favorable aussi à ses amendements les
autres ce thèse ils écoutent c'est tout
alors je veux bien que que le décorum de
cette émission que notre salle des
conférences que notre palais du
Luxembourg
fasse un petit peu Second Empire c'est
clair mais que notre Sénat bascule dans
sa pratique vers un tel
bonapartiste non non
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
les amendements qui ont été élus par le
ministre ce sont ceux qui vont recevoir
un avis favorable
mais nous verrons tous les amendements
qui restent dans l'allias nous verrons
donc le petit millier d'amendements qui
nous reste dans la liasse ceux qui ont
été cités par le ministre sont ceux qui
ont un a priori favorable monsieur
Bocquet pour rappel au règlement
oui merci madame la Présidente
en vertu de l'article 49 notre règlement
effectivement je voudrais d'abord donner
lecture de la ligne à 3 de l'article 44
de la Constitution sur lequel on est en
train de se prononcer les uns et les
autres je le cite si le gouvernement le
demande
l'assemblée saisie se prononce par un
seul vote sur tout ou partie du texte en
discussion en ne retenant que les
amendements proposés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement fin de citation
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire il y a
quelques jours ici que il n'y avait plus
au Sénat qu'un seul bloc libéral pour
soutenir cette réforme libérale il y a
un accord de fond on le sait ça n'est
pas une surprise mais là on est en train
d'assister à une forme de sabordage du
Sénat dans cette république il y avait
le bicamérisme j'ai envie de parler à
l'imparfait malheureusement le Sénat
joue son rôle dans cette république mais
là on est en train de le saborder et où
est la séparation des pouvoirs dans
cette situation c'est gravissime ce qui
est en train de se passer le ministre
choisit les amendements publics
conviennent sincèrement ce moment est
grave je veux le dire avec solennité
après la crise économique qui sévit
depuis longtemps dans ce pays la crise
sociale qui est en train de s'exprimer
vous allez ajouter une fiche politique
majeure dans un pays fracturé et en
tension
madame madame la Présidente se rappelle
au règlement en vertu de l'article 44
bis de notre règlement intérieur
aujourd'hui vous piétinez le Sénat avec
la complicité de la droite sénateur
gouvernement est responsable de ce qui
se passe depuis le début en ayant choisi
justement l'utilisation du 47 ans qui
limite les débats qui n'ont pas permis
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
d'aller au bout des débats et qui
brutalise à nouveau à travers
l'utilisation de cet article de la
Constitution 44-3 pour brutaliser le
Sénat vous avez une pratique du pouvoir
brutal vous prouvez à travers tous ces
artifices l'essoufflement de cette
république de cette cinquième république
aujourd'hui vous en faites à nouveau la
démonstration d'ailleurs
hasard du calendrier sort aujourd'hui un
livre intitulé une république à bout de
souffle que je vous recommande justement
de lire elle montre à quel point les
contradictions les archaïsmes de cette
constitution sa vulnérabilité qui
augmente face aux tentations
autoritaires et qu'un nouveau partage
des pouvoirs serait savateur pour une
république enfin sociale et écologiste
mais face ce coup de force que vous
essayez de faire c'est un coup de force
contre les Françaises et les Françaises
qui se battent aussi contre cette
réforme c'est eux que vous brutalisez à
travers ces outils quand vous brutalisez
notre le Parlement c'est pour ça que
malgré tous ces artifices nous serons
nombreux nous appelons justement les
Françaises et les Françaises de ce
mobiliser en masse encore plus nombreux
et nombreuses face à cette volonté de
nous brutaliser car samedi nous serons
avec eux dans la rue
désormais les Français
à partir du moment où leur privé
dedans au sein du Parlement monsieur
kerouge vous demande de faire votre
appel au règlement en indiquant
l'article auquel vous faites référence
[Musique]
c'est Monsieur kerouchki à la part à la
parole pour son rappel au règlement
monsieur kerouche sur quel fondement du
rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente
encore une remarque à notre collègue
Hainaut parce qu'il nous interpelle vous
êtes obsédé monsieur par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous faites une fixation il y
a de très bonnes consultations
psychologique en ce qui nous concerne en
ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
socialistes écologistes et communiste
bien
un bel exercice quand même commun de
médiocrité parlementaire parce que
vous nous expliquez l'ensemble des
mesures ou des dispositions que nous
aurions prises pour ne pas faire avancer
le débat ou pour faire obstruction ceci
étant je rappelle notamment pour le
Conseil constitutionnel que par exemple
il y a une collusion évidente entre la
commission des affaires sociales et sa
présidente et le gouvernement parce que
en ne réussissant en ne réunissant pas
la commission cela permettait de mettre
en place l'article 44 alinéa 2 c'est de
la collusion ensuite vous avez utilisé
l'article 38 avec une seule prise de
parole l'article 42 10 le temps
déterminé l'article 44-6 sur les
priorités l'article 46 bises 2 sur les
examens disjoints l'article 46 bis 4
dites-moi vraiment qui a fait de
l'obstruction parlementaire qui
en fait
en fait nous aurons eu avec ce débat la
preuve que cette réforme était mauvaise
je salue la présence de Frank Leicester
qui le premier a manifester le fait que
cette réforme se faisait au détriment
des femmes et bien tout le long de
l'examen tout le long de l'examen nous
aurons montré que cette réforme est très
mauvaise et je terminerai par une
formule bien connue mais elle est
vraiment vérifiée aujourd'hui la
roche-tard Payenne n'est pas loin du
capital du Capitole pardon
je voyais monsieur Karoutchi je
voyais les mais très sérieusement le
succès que vous pensez avoir aujourd'hui
et déjà la défaite de demain
pour rappel
aux règles mes amours
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
le temps du débat c'est le gouvernement
qui la volontairement réduit d'abord en
soumettant l'examen de ce texte à
l'article 47.1 qui oblige à finir ce
débat dimanche minuit et qui ensuite
refusent d'ouvrir ce qui reste possible
le débat au-delà de dimanche minuit il
serait d'ailleurs peut-être
encore temps de le faire parce qu'il
reste un certain nombre d'amendements à
exposer et je pense que si vous vouliez
vraiment montrer que vous êtes prêt au
débat vous ouvrirez la séance au-delà de
dimanche la majorité sénatoriale ne
s'est en effet pas grandi de prêter le
flanc à toutes ces manœuvres elle s'est
réduite à une béquille du gouvernement
en se prenant les pieds dans le tapis
puisque toutes les procédures activées
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant non
contribué qu'à une seule chose c'est à
retard er encore le débat et à ne pas
avancer sur l'examen du texte
je crois que ce vote bloqué vous
l'activez aussi parce que dans la
majorité sénatoriale comme dans la
majorité présidentielle les fractures et
les lézards se font de plus en plus
ouvertes ici je l'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire et je vais le redire 55 de nos
collègues qui appartiennent au bord de
la droite et du centre ont refusé de
voter l'article 7 c'est ça qui vous pose
problème je tiens c'est absolument leur
droit et nous les en félicitons ce qui
est en revanche irresponsable c'est que
à activer ce petit frère du 49-3 vous
allez redoubler la colère du pays et
c'est absolument irresponsable dans le
contexte où nous sommes pour ce qui nous
concerne nous allons continuer de
défendre argument après argument les
méfaits de cette réforme qui repousse
l'âge de la retraite de deux ans vous
pouvez compter sur nous nous ne
lâcherons pas sur chacun de nos
arguments
monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'avais vu
que le président rotaïo s'était inscrit
avant moi j'espère que je lui passe pas
devant
vous avez perdu le débat politique
l'utilisation du 49-3 sénatorial c'est
la preuve que vous avez perdue le débat
politique vous avez d'abord accepté le
47 heures la procédure contrainte pour
les débats y compris vous avez un texte
qui a pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale puis ici après l'obstruction
silencieuse vous avez utilisé
l'obstruction réglementaire en allant
chercher ce bouquin au fin fond d'une
armoire poussiéreuse avec des arguments
et des règlements qui n'avaient jamais
utilisé été utilisé auparavant et je
vous le redis vous ne réglerez pas la
question politique par des argusies
réglementaires et maintenant vous vous
en remettez au gouvernement qui active
l'arme du 49-3 sénatorial pour mettre
fin
à nos débats mais le débat il continue à
l'extérieur des millions de travailleurs
et travailleuses se sont mis puissamment
en grève et celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'ils sachent une chose nous
continuerons à défendre nos arguments et
nos amendements jusqu'au bout vous allez
être contraintes d'entendre tout ce que
nous voulions débattre et il faut
continuer à se mobiliser puissamment
samedi parce que nous voulons une chose
et nous ne céderons rien et les trois
groupes de gauche écologistes
socialistes et communiste resteront uni
et rassemblée jusqu'au retrait de cette
réforme unique et chers collègues vous
êtes rentrés très fort et majoritaire
vous en sortez affaibli et tout petit et
si vous pensez que vous allez régler la
chose à 14 dans une salle en CMP contre
la majoritaire des Français vous vous
gourouez merci chers
ça vole de lit pour rappel au règlement
monsieur symbole d'Élie pour rappel au
règlement
oui merci 44 bises
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues d'abord je trouve que
franchement
j'écoutais madame borne qui nous
rappelait mercredi
elle a évoqué la séparation des pouvoirs
je suis assez scandalisé de la
proposition du missile du socle en
l'absence du président du Sénat
c'est un événement important pour notre
institution donc on choisit pas
on minimum on se respecte et je peux
d'autant plus me dire que vous le savez
mes collègues Galler j'ai porte une
appréciation assez dure à l'encontre de
notre président à un moment donné de nos
débats avec vous me connaissez avec ma
sincérité s'agissant l'obstruction
monsieur Hainaut alors là franchement
ne portons pas des mots plus hauts on
n'a pas besoin d'invective ici personne
n'a avoir honte moi je vais vous dire
des 145 LR des 145 élèves il y a la 127
qu'on vote pour mais les autres n'ont
qu'une honte à avoir les centristes
étaient 50 157 INAC 35 ont voté pour
mais les autres n'ont pas de honte à
avoir les indépendants Républiques et
territoires sont 24 22 ont voté pour les
deux autres n'ont pas de honte à avoir
et je peux continuer la liste comme ça
donc il n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il
n'y a pas eu d'obstruction il y a des
parlementaires des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui ont eu l'occasion
d'exprimer des votes contraires donc il
n'y a pas eu obstruction du débat vous
n'avez pas changer compris des éléments
de votre majorité c'est pas sérieux et
puis après là quand même on est dans un
duo là franchement c'est impressionnant
on a un article 7 qui est réécrit en duo
en 10 minutes après on nous a fait
l'article 38 moi je vais vous dire ce
qui est en train de se passer vous êtes
en train de créer un régime des pleins
pouvoirs voilà ce que vous êtes en train
de faire et vous et je le dis à la
majorité c'est noriade sénatoriale en
acceptant le diktak du gouvernement vous
êtes en train de faire de la béquille
parce que vous êtes en train de préparer
un nouveau régime parce qu'on est en
train d'affaiblir les deux assemblées le
pouvoir parlementaire et je vous dis ça
sans invective et sans polémique il y a
82 % de Français en colère ce matin
82% de français en colère ce matin
Madame Van egg pour rappel au règlement
et madame la présidente rappelle au
règlement en vertu de l'article 44 bis
personne n'est dupe monsieur le ministre
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale
votre pénible liste à la Prévert de
justification à votre décision de
piétiner l'opposition n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
ici et avec la brutalité qui s'est
exprimée
c'est vous monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale qui nous avait
muselé bâillonné
bâillonné embarrassé embarrassé que vous
êtes
par nos arguments et nos propositions en
opposition à votre réforme réactionnaire
et néfaste pour les Français
les Français n'y comprennent plus rien
mais il va savoir que c'est un coup
d'État que vous venez de déclencher ici
au Sénat
et vous allez tristement aujourd'hui
marquer l'histoire
j'ai oublié pour rappel au règlement
merci Madame la prudente au moins trois
articles 46 bits 44 bits 44 terre
je
à cet instant je constate que la
discussion a démarré avec un accord
politique légitime oui oui monsieur
carochi légitime entre la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement sur le
fond d'un texte
vous nous avez donné l'habitude d'être
plus placide chers
et cet accord politique s'est transformé
et c'est là qu'elle problème en accord
institutionnel
la constitution de notre République elle
donne beaucoup de pouvoir à l'exécutif
plus que dans tout autre démocratie par
le mentale et le règlement du Sénat il
tente de préserver les droits de
l'institution parlementaire
l'activation du 49-3 fait partie des
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
gouvernement 44-3 pardon constitutionnel
du gouvernement le ministre choisit de
l'activer
mais là nous avons assisté à autre chose
nous avons assisté à une majorité
sénatoriale qui a organisé l'activation
de cet article avec le gouvernement
il en résulte une confusion
institutionnelle qui est grave vous ne
défendez plus le Sénat vous utilisez les
outils que notre Constitution donne à
l'exécutif pour activer accélérer
l'adoption d'un texte au Sénat vous
n'utilisez pas le fait majoritaire là
vous utilisez vous vous pliez à une
demande de gouvernement avec les outils
de l'exécutif et ça c'est grave et ça
c'est grave parce que je comprends que
le fait majoritaire vous donne le droit
de faire voter un texte vous pouvez vous
exclamer
comme nos droits d'opposants nous
donnent le droit d'activer les outils
pour le freiner mais là vous avez
franchi le Rubicon vous êtes mis dans la
main de l'exécutif
que broyer pour rappel au règlement
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame madame
la Présidente au nom de l'article 42 9
et à propos de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution
nous parlions au début de ces débats de
des traditionnels débats feutrés du
Sénat et nous allons terminer sur des
débats Bayonnais la démocratie se mesure
au respect des minorités mais aussi des
syndicats des corps sociaux pour les
syndicats lorsqu'ils demandent à être
reçus par le Président de la République
la première ministre les renvoie dans le
bureau de Monsieur du soft
du respect je ne le sais pas sans
vouloir manquer de respect au ministre
je pense que l'ampleur de la
manifestation nécessitait que le
président l'ai reçu en ce qui nous
concerne après le choix d'un véhicule
législatif qui contraint nos débat et
qui nous oblige à terminer dans les
délais contraints fixés par l'article
47.1 pour voter vite trop vite cette
mauvaise réforme avec votre accord et
l'âge chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale voilà donc le 44 3 utilisé
pour bâillonner c'est le mot
l'opposition sénatoriale et hélas je le
dis avec la complicité de la majorité
sénatoriale je suis tout récent ici j'ai
toujours vu les sénateurs bataillés pour
le respect de leurs droits et de la
capacité d'agir et de débattre du
Parlement
et si cette capacité est mise à mal
après que reste-t-il que reste-t-il
chers collègues lorsque les
manifestations sont méprisées monsieur
le ministre que reste-t-il quel article
de la Constitution permet de bâillonner
des millions de manifestants et vers
quel régime allons-nous aller
pour rappel au règlement pardon monsieur
Dantec
oui merci madame la présidente rappelle
au règlement évidemment sur la base du
44 bijoux je voudrais vous relire
l'article 28 le Premier ministre après
consultation du président de l'assemblée
concernée ou la majorité des membres de
chaque assemblée peut décider la tenue
de jour supplémentaire de séance avec le
47 ans nous avons 50 jours nous pouvons
donc aller plus tard que dimanche si
vous vouliez vraiment que nous
débâtirons vous aviez la possibilité par
la constitution de rajouter des jours et
c'est ce que j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
hier soir simplement vous ne le voulez
pas et ce matin vous avez même multiplié
les
provocations y compris pour se faire
tomber 10 ou amendements pour justement
arriver à ce que vous aviez décidé
depuis déjà longtemps je crois
qu'effectivement ça a été dit par mes
collègues c'est un affaiblissement
terrible du Parlement c'est un
affaiblissement du Sénat avec le soutien
de la majorité sénatorial et je vais pas
être très très long
ça parlera aux quelques gaullistes qui
sont encore sur les bandes droites je
crois que le titre de ce qui se passe ce
matin c'est balle tragique au Sénat un
mort la société française qui sort plus
fragilisée que jamais
monsieur Paco pour rappel au règlement
oui madame la Présidente merci en vertu
de l'article alors on a entendu des mots
quand même assez fort le président
Kanner a parlé de réactionnaire
notre ami salvaudellie a parlé des
pleins pouvoirs les pleins pouvoirs ils
ont été votés à Pétain en juillet 40
c'est quand même une référence navrante
on a parlé de bonapartisme ce n'est pas
le 18 brumaire le ministre du socle
n'est pas Joachim Murat il n'y a pas de
grenadier pour vous sortir d'ici
vous avez parlé
il n'y a qu'un seul regret c'est que
nous soyons contraints de subir ce que
vous appelez un 49-3 sénatorial nous
aurions tous aimé vous comme nous mais
peut-être pas avec la même sincérité
aller jusqu'au bout du vrai débat cette
espèce de 49-3 sénatorial il est
provoqué il est provoqué il faut que
vous l'assumiez par votre coagulation
des débats votre attitude aboutissait à
une embolie sénatoriale et je suis navré
de conclure en utilisant la morale du
rat et de l'huître de la Fontaine tel
est pris qui croyait prendre
monsieur ozulias pour rappel au
règlement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mais mes chers collègues les
Français et les Françaises nous
regardent et ne comprennent qu'une seule
chose face à cette émission les
républicains du Sénat sont entrés au
gouvernement voilà ce que les Français
comprennent aujourd'hui nous sommes face
à une crise politique majeure majeur
l'autorité du Président de la République
est en question l'autorité de la
première ministre est en question le
groupe majoritaire de l'Assemblée
nationale a éclaté il ne reste plus
qu'au gouvernement l'assurance de
pouvoir disposer des votes du groupe
républicain au Sénat chers collègues je
vous pose la question est-ce que vous
allez sauver le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron
monsieur dossier pour rappel au
règlement sous quel fondement monsieur
dessus
sur le 44 bis madame la Présidente merci
on va remettre un peu de contexte parce
que j'entends un peu n'importe quoi qui
a raconté sur les rangs de la droite
qui réécrit qui réécrit largement
l'histoire de ce débat qui réécrit
largement l'histoire de ce débat on a eu
un débat sur un jusqu'à mardi à peu près
on a étudié jusqu'à 6 articles
sereinement ça a été long évidemment
mais on a étudié six articles
sereinement jusqu'à mardi mardi il s'est
passé quelque chose les Françaises sont
levés ils sont ils vous ont dit à quel
point ils rejetaient cette réforme les
grèves ont commencé à se mettre en place
et là ça a été le début de la panique
début de la panique c'est 1000
amendements de la gauche qui sont tombés
pour un effet de procédure ensuite ça a
été la montée en puissance du règlement
42 38 44 de hier mais aussi les débuts
de la fissure on a vu certains de des
sénateurs de droite et du centre qui ne
votaient pas l'article 7
on a vu aussi qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
les menaces commençaient à pleuvoir sur
les les députés de la majorité qui ne
voteraient pas ce texte aujourd'hui pour
12 sous amendements 12 sous amendements
c'est une demi-heure de débat 12 sous
amendements le ministre a craqué il a
sorti le 44 3
il nous reste 900 amendements 900
amendements
oui les 1000 1000
1000 sous amendements il nous restait
trois jours de débat on aurait même plus
ouvrir une journée de plus on aurait pu
aller au bout c'était les débats sur le
sucré de la réforme sur les mesures
d'athénomation de la brutalité de la
réforme on a vu hier quand on a commencé
à les débattre qu'on avait même plus à
les expliquer ici que personne ne
comprenait que c'est que ces mesures
d'atténuation n'étaient pas à la hauteur
donc on la revient on vient comprendre
ce qui se passe c'est à dire que vous
n'arrivez pas à masquer la brutalité de
la réforme vous arriverez plus à
l'assumer ces débats et donc vous
essayez de nous faire taire tout le
monde l'a compris mais vous n'y
arriverez pas et demain les versions
seront massives monsieur Tissot pour
rappel au règlement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon rappel
au règlement sera sur la base de
l'article 42 alinéa neuf de notre
règlement alors que l'avenir des
Françaises et les Français est en jeu et
que nous débattuons du droit à avoir une
retraite en bonne santé et un repos
mérité après de longues carrières
érintantes je suis profondément choqué
par le contournement du Parlement et du
débat démocratique décidé par le
gouvernement en seulement 30 minutes
chers collègues de la majorité
sénatorial en acceptant la proposition
du gouvernement prenez-vous conscience
de ce que vous venez d'accepter alors
que vous cessez vous ne cessez de
rappeler la grandeur du Sénat à laquelle
je crois vous venez de réduire au néant
son rôle institutionnel au sein de notre
République
je souhaitais revenir sur les propos de
notre collègue qui parlaient
d'obstruction honteuse des groupes de
gauche et vous mon cher collègue
n'avez-vous pas honte de refuser un
débat sur un texte qui privera les
Français de deux ans de vie et de
projets à accomplir
moi j'aime bien quand la droite
manifeste quand je parle parce que ça
veut dire que moi en tant qu'élile
gauche je touche juste
monsieur du soft monsieur le ministre
vous justifiez cette manœuvre de
contournement vous faire aboutir un
texte de loi
soi-disant de justice sociale pourtant
mardi dernier plus de 6000 personnes
étaient réunies dans une ville que vous
connaissez bien Annonay commune vous
avez été maire député de cette
circonscription commune qui joue
justement des partement de nombreux
manifestements rappelaient qu'il y a 12
ans vous manifestiez alors côté contre
la réforme des retraites d'Éric worth en
dénonçant et se sont vos mots de
l'époque une réforme doublement injuste
pensez-vous cette fois que votre réforme
est juste monsieur le ministre je pense
que l'ensemble des interventions que
nous avons vu sur le rappel aux
règlements monsieur le colistre demande
la parole
merci
merci madame la Présidente la semaine la
Présidente je souhaitais finalement
réagir à quelques-uns des rappels au
règlement sur un point en particulier
mais monsieur Tissot évoquant une
commune qui m'est cher m'invite
finalement à réagir plus vite encore
qu'est-ce que je le pensais je dis ça
vous avez évoqué la manifestation qui
s'est déroulée dans ma commune c'est où
j'habite et ça me permet d'apporter un
élément nouveau et je le dis en
précisant que aucun destinateur ici
présent n'est responsable de cela j'ai
indiqué il y a quelques heures de débat
maintenant peut-être deux jours que de
10h à 15h 2400 foyers de ma commune
avait été privé d'électricité après une
coupure volontaire
cette coupure volontaire a entraîné la
nécessité pour les lycées de fermer leur
porte à empêcher les commerçants de
travailler à nécessité que les pompiers
interviennent pour débloquer délivrer
plus exactement des personnes bloquées
dans des ascenseurs à contraint les
résidents d'un foyer de personnes âgées
à manger froid et des interventions de
pompiers pour des personnes placées sous
respirateur et à causer le désordre que
vous imaginez cette coupure volontaire
monsieur le sénateur a été depuis
revendiqué par la CGT énergie
si c'est de ce mouvement social dont
vous réclamez je ne suis pas sûr que ça
participe à la clarté ou la légitimité
des débats
ensuite
j'ai entendu à plusieurs reprises des
mots qui je crois dépassent largement le
cadre de nos débats
j'ai entendu et les rappels et du cas
des rappels le règlement mais monsieur
le Président
moi-même c'est la terre je n'ose me
prononcer sur cet aspect là sur les mots
que j'ai entendu coup de force bâillon
censure régime libéral
idémocratique coup d'État régime
autoritaire je crois véritablement que
ça n'est pas nécessairement adéquate
lorsqu'on met en oeuvre une procédure
prévue par la Constitution par notre
texte principal par des dispositions qui
autorisent le gouvernement à solliciter
du Parlement une seule chose c'est la
clarté d'impositionnement et d'un débat
j'ai aussi entendu des discours ou des
interventions offusqués disant mais
finalement que faites-vous personne n'a
jamais osé faire cela c'est absolument
incroyable
les quelques rappels qui se sont
succédés m'ont permis de consulter les
archives du Sénat le 20 avril 2013 après
18h de débats après l'examen de 156
amendements sur les 679 qui étaient
déposés sur le projet de loi relatif à
la sécurisation professionnelle
qui comptait 20 articles c'est le hasard
de la comparaison un de mes
prédécesseurs Michel Sapin
avait recours à l'article 44.2
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas de
possibilités autre pour faire aboutir le
texte et c'est d'autant plus
[Musique]